Candid Truth. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. It's me and Aubrey and we got a
special guest. You guys might remember
him from the two shows we did before
this about all the politics and things
that are going on right here in America
that all loads all roads lead to Rome.
Like it is so in your face. If you
haven't seen the Washington DC video we
did, you guys should check that out.
It'll be linked in the end here, but I'm
going to introduce Minnow up in here.
What's up, Minnow? Doing doing good.
Doing good. Live from Las Vegas. Uh not
Nashville this time. Well, I was
actually at your you guys place last
time, but yeah, I had to I had to go
here for work, but uh uh this was a good
opportunity uh to do a live show. I was
like, "Yeah, let's do it." Awesome, man.
Yeah, man. And Minnow's ready to go any
any any place anytime.
And and God's really giving Yeah, man.
God's really giving you eyes to see and
some discernment cuz if you just sit
down and have like a five hour
conversation with this guy, man, it goes
from the music industry, the Christian
music industry, uh, new apost apost I
don't even know how to say that word,
apostolic reformation, politics. I mean,
you really are putting the pieces
together. It's it's funny what what
before you were we were praying and you
said like yeah you know connecting the
dots and that's exactly how I see it
like it's just that's what that's what I
just
god-given you know that that I see like
I I see connections everywhere right so
me too man hence my website nar
connections and connecting the dots yeah
it's oh you got a website
nconnections.com
Yeah, that's purely the new apostolic
reformation. So there you see all the
pastors that are connected with uh the
N. Um however,
since then I've been I've been, you
know, researching more and more and uh
then I all of a sudden saw the
government involved, right? And then
you're looking like, okay, hm, there's
more going on than than only the N. Then
you see that Rome is involved and then
you see all these things coming together
like ah that's what what's going on
here. So yeah, I'm the same way man. You
see that all roads indeed lead to Rome.
Definitely. And it is it's it's in the
Hollywood, it's in music industry, all
that stuff. And I know that people can
get sick of hearing about it. So I I
don't even point out stuff that I see
sometimes. But once once God has given
your eyes eyes to see and knock the
scales off, the blinders off your eyes,
it's like you see right through it all.
Just like our intro. That's why the
intro is him putting on those glasses
and seeing Taylor Swift is really a
demon and all these things. Not
literally. I'm not saying she a demon. I
don't know. But she is openly showing
who she who she serves when she's
dressed like a demon just like a lot of
these um musicians and Hollywood people
and all that. But yeah, you can really
see right through all the
deceptions. And we have an advantage
that a lot of people don't have uh
discernment and even we don't have all
of it. That's the scary part. As much as
we know, we still only know the tip of
the iceberg, honestly. Mhm. Yeah. And it
and it's nothing of ourselves. I can I
can say that even as a Christian for
eight years, eight and a half years, I
was blind, man. I was like I didn't even
I couldn't even tell that Harry Potter
was pushing witchcraft. I was one of
those people like, man, whatever. It's a
kids book. And now I'm like, "Yeah, it's
a kids book. Why are they putting this
in there?" You know? It's like, "What in
the world?"
But yeah, man. I'm excited to get into
what we got. You want to go through the
slides? Yeah. Yeah. We're we're we're
going to show you again. I mean, and and
again, I I think I said it last time and
I say it again. Um if you're a Trump
supporter after all the shows that we
do, uh I think you will see that uh he
is not what he says he is and uh he is
just pushing the same agenda. Uh and
we're going to show it all. We're gonna
and we're gonna get candid with it.
Right. That's right. Let's get candid
with it, bro. the truth. Let let's let's
let the truth out. And uh here you see
Trump's new world order and it's not
completely Trump's, but that's what uh
uh just a caveat. This guy thinks that
Trump is the antichrist. I don't think
so. Uh we don't think so. Uh but he a
lot of content that he has is is quite
quite good and and some material
definitely usable and and eye opening.
So yeah, we can start with this one. And
yeah, you know what's interesting is I
never even I I the way I understand
prophecy is that there's going to the
world's going to get into chaos and and
the enemy is using cha order out of
chaos. So he has to create chaos so that
Satan can appear as the savior and save
the day and everybody's going to be
ready to accept him because they're at a
place of hopelessness. It's like this
world is in chaos. We need a savior. All
the superhero movies are priming you. We
need a hero. And it's going to look
like it's going to look like a revival.
It's going to look so close to the
truth. And that's where a lot of these
movies that we grew up on, Left Behind
and all that, they get it wrong. They
say, "No, we're looking for an evil
president, you know, and and they're
looking for this man that just hates
Christianity. He's killing him in the
streets and all this stuff, but that's
not deceptive. You know that's in your
face. Satan's going to deceive the whole
world. Only a remnant, only an elect are
not going to be deceived. And it's going
to look like peace and safety. That's
not cutting. That's not killing
Christians in the street. It's going to
look like revival. It's going to be like
a one world religion where look, we all
let's just agree on what we let's just
uh agree on what we agree on or
whatever, you know? let's put our
differences aside and let's just all
agree that God is real and God is love
and all these things. And so I'm
starting to see that kind of stuff in
the presidencies and everything that
more talk of God and and that sounds
like a good thing. That's why it seems
weird to hear Christians criticizing
that the government's talking more about
God because it sounds so good. It sounds
so it's so close to the truth is
something that you think you would want.
But that's exactly what happened in
Rome. Mhm. They had a guise of
Christianity and if you don't worship
this way, you get killed, burn at the
stake. And we know according to prophecy
that that's what's going to happen
again. There's going to be a one world
religion. If you don't worship this way,
you will die. Um all that to say the the
kind of epiphany and I would even even
say that that happened uh in that sense
also like uh uh I think I think I mean
there are so many times that people have
talked about it like with Nebuchadnezzar
right uh yeah it's a repetition
repetition over and over
and this is this is the result right
this is what what what it looks so good
you go from one chaos to to the other
Yeah.
Uh and
history you for forced worship again,
right? So it already happened multiple
times, right? It's going to happen
again. And the point I was getting to is
the kind of epiphany that I had or I
feel like God was showing me something.
I don't know. Only time will tell, I
guess. But I feel like these markers
that that Trump has that look like the
Antichrist. I'm wondering if Trump is
being set up as some kind of like
Antichrist decoy. Like it it looks so
good. Oh, gas prices are cheaper and
he's getting rid of the woke stuff and
look, everything's going good. And then
all of a sudden they're going to be
like, "Wait a minute. This is the
Antichrist. He's talking about peace and
safety." Yeah. He's talking about peace
and safety. He He suffered a fatal head
wound and survived. Now he's now they're
talking about new world order and he's
talking about Stargate where it's AI
governance and all this stuff. They're
gonna be like, "Wait a minute. We fell
for the Antichrist because Satan knows
that the Christians are looking for an
antichrist first." So in order for Satan
to come as Christ. Nobody's going to
fall for that. Most Christians are
looking for an antichrist first. So
Christ can't or Satan can't appear as
Christ unless he sets up an antichrist
decoy first. And so Trump may be that
and then Satan can come on the scene and
defeat Trump in one way or another and
everybody's going to be like, "Now
that's the true Christ when he comes as
a supernatural being doing miracles,
bringing out fire from heaven, signs and
wonders, all these things." So yeah.
Well, and last time we talked about it a
little bit um uh about about the same
subject. Um and uh the whole I mean the
whole um uh Christ I mean the majority
of Christians are now you know the
pre-trip uh uh um how do you call them
dispositionalists right? Uh that's the
majority right now. Um and and yeah, if
if this is if this is continuing, people
will see him as as at some some point as
the Antichrist. He might he's a builder.
They asked him several times if he wants
to build the the third temple, right? So
yeah, that's right.
Yeah, man. We're getting into into stuff
that we're going into in the future, but
uh let's uh look what let's watch this
video first. All right. Here's what's
fascinating. All of the movement toward
a new world order in recent years pales
in comparison to what we are seeing
happening right now all around the world
and even in the last couple of days.
Let's look at just a few things. Donald
Trump has literally remade the
government of the most powerful nation
in the world into his own image,
installing diehard loyalists in just
about every part of the federal
bureaucracy. He is doing whatever he
wants on a daily basis and no one is
standing up to him. In Europe, Germany's
new leader is openly promising a major
shift in relations with the United
States as his country and the rest of
Europe react to Trump's policies. Europe
as a whole is also now talking about
developing homegrown nuclear weapons in
order to defend itself as America can no
longer be relied on in their eyes. We
see other American allies such as Canada
and Greenland react in horror to the
comments of Trump and frantically search
for ways to protect themselves from any
actions that he might take against them.
Then there is the United States aligning
itself with Russia in the Ukraine Russia
war. Trump has even referred to Zalinski
as a dictator but not Putin. And Trump
blamed Ukraine for starting the war but
not Russia. Even the peace talks to end
the Ukraine Russia war did not involve
Ukraine itself. Just today we saw
another example of the burgeoning
America Russia alliance as the United
States voted against a UN resolution
that condemned Russia's invasion of
Ukraine. The resolution passed with most
of Europe supporting it. Meanwhile,
considering how Trump sided with Russia
over Ukraine and his threats against
Canada, China has to be salivating about
Taiwan. It's seemingly just a matter of
time before they seize the island,
knowing that Trump will not stop them.
As if all of these geopolitical changes
weren't enough, we also have Pope
Francis very ill and reportedly even
considering resigning. As a reminder,
there are more than 1.3 billion
Catholics in the world, nearly 18% of
the global population. So all around the
world we can see alliances changing
right in front of us. NATO is on the way
out. Europe is in shock over the United
States abandoning them. Russia and
America joining together. And America
itself threatening to absorb other parts
of the world into their kingdom. Perhaps
the strangest part about how a new world
order is now so quickly forming, thanks
in large part to Donald Trump, is that
the seeds for this new world order might
have been planted in Trump's brain 40
years ago. You see, back in the 1980s,
Trump kept a book on his nightstand
called My New Order. That book was
written by Adolf Hitler, and it was the
sequel to Mine Comp, which means My
Struggle. Originally published in 1941,
My New Order chimed in at more than
1,000 pages and was a collection of
Hitler's speeches from the 1920s and the
1930s.
Wow, dude. That's interesting.
Troubling. Yeah. Isn't that
bizarre? It's it's uh so so I mean you
that's what you see, right? the whole
alliance with with kind of with Putin in
a way and then pushing, right? So, it's
kind of like pushing back and forth. Uh
and uh u my business partner uh for work
uh he uh from my uh one of my uh
companies uh he uh he's in
Slovakia and uh he is uh his government
is uh is aligning with
Putin. So you see a whole shift uh you
know going on all across the globe like
what you know uh shifting and uh uh
we're not going to go too deep in this
but uh this is a cliffhanger for the end
of the next episode that we're going to
do. Awesome. Yeah, this is going to be
15 episodes something like that. Oh
yeah, I don't know going two episodes
that that were that we're planning right
now. this one and the next one was
actually one. So, I don't know. We'll
see what the future brings.
But yeah, it's it's insane. It's insane
how how things and we just talked about
like like how how things are shifting uh
into Christianity, but also how uh world
alliances basically are everything is
moving to the right, right? Everything
is moving to the to the you see that in
Europe, you see that in uh in here in
the US. So it's u and even in South
America you see
uh like Argentina and some others that
are extremely on the right side. So
right the pendulum has been so far crazy
left and now it's it's swinging right
but it's going to be a a false it's
going to be a false system of worship
basically.
Yeah. So, you know, just like, and you
know, this might be offensive, but if
you see a Catholic, most people will
consider them, oh, they're Christian.
They believe in the Bible. They believe
in Jesus and all that, but Catholicism
is not Christian. Catholicism is
paganism veiled in Christian icon
iconography. Um, everything about it is
anti-Christian. And all the reformers
knew that the Roman system was or the
the papacy was the antichrist system.
That's been forgotten. But that's what
we knew prophetically was going to
happen that Satan is going to form a a
system that looks like Christianity, but
it's going to be false. And it's today's
world, the world's largest Christian
denomination.
So it's being successful and it's now
joining hands with
evangelical world because for a long
time growing up it was it was different.
You're either Christian or you're
Catholic. But now you see people like u
Francis Chan and Kenneth Copelan and all
these people having
um priests, Catholic priests come up and
speak and having interviews with the
Pope and saying, "Well, I guess we're
all Catholic again. the Reformation's
over and the the protest is over. We're
all Catholic again. And it's like, wow,
this is so prophetic.
And and everybody is like, uh, yay.
Yeah. Peace and safety. We're all
uniting. Kumbaya.
Yeah. Coexist. You know, like the bumper
stickers you always see, coexist. It's a
beautiful thing. You look at it, you're
like, yeah, why can't we all just get
along? I get it. But you can't
compromise truth just to get along, you
know? Right. That's where you get into
like, oh, well, maybe there are 86
genders. Let's just agree to disagree.
Let's let's like just be peaceful about
it or whatever. Friends. Yeah. Somehow.
Correct. Correct. So, uh let's see the
next slide what we have. Um so,
uh a little bit of technology. So, it's
funny because I'm in Las Vegas for uh
for an technology conference exhibition.
Um and uh
but it's it's very interesting where
where this is going. Uh and
um this is something where
um the whole antichrist system is not
able to function if the technology is
not in place. Right? So, uh, and and
what Elon Musk and what the what they're
doing with the whole with Stargate and
and whatnot, and we're getting into all
that more deeper in later episodes, but,
you know, more about
technocracy, but um, they want to go to
a singularity basically, and that's
basically where, uh, where, um,
AI basically is is is ruling the the
whole the whole uh AI governance
basically because that's the solution.
It's unbiased, right? So you have the
left, the right. Well, then you have AI.
Yeah. And AI is
basically is not um how you said it is
uh nonpartisan or whatever, right? It's
unbiased.
Unbiased. Yeah. So if you have an
unbiased judge, that literally puts AI
as God because God is the ultimate
judge. He's not going to take, you know,
he's not going to favor one side or
another. It's either black or white.
It's right or wrong. And we attach
emotions to things and say, "Oh, well,
this lifestyle is not wrong because it
feels so good or whatever." And if you
have some kind of judge that's judging
according to what it's been programmed
to, or whatever, then you're making AI
God.
Yep. Yep. And that's where where it's
going to. Um, and that's what you see.
So, here uh Ila Musk is tweeting this
out and uh if you click to the to to the
next uh video uh the next one is a video
uh you'll see uh what uh what what it
what this what this is what it looks
like uh where it's going. All right,
let's take it. Elon Musk made a very
chilling statement when he came out and
said that we are approaching the event
horizon or basically at the event
horizon of the
singularity. That's a big he's talking
about this right here. We are on the
event horizon of the singularity. I
guess it's just a coincidence that the
plot to the 1997 movie the horizon is
about a ship's drive opening a gateway
to a hellish dimension outside of the
known universe. implied to be hell and
that event horizon has attained
sentience. Go figure that the image used
for Grock is a black hole which is the
singularity which also has clear Saturn
symbolism which I'll come back to. Now
the majority of people who hear about
the singularity they automatically think
about AI or technology with the AI
singularity which is a hypothetical
future when artificial intelligence
surpasses human intelligence. But at the
root, the base definition to the
singularity is the quality or state of
being singular or becoming one. And this
is exactly why he chose the name gro for
his artificial intelligence because it
means to understand so thoroughly that
the observer becomes a part of the
observed to merge, blend, intermarry,
lose identity. So the true singularity
is coming for those who choose the
narrow path that leads to life that is
Jesus Christ. you will become one
becoming singular with him. And for
those who choose the broad road that
leads to destruction, going towards this
world system, going towards their own
self-righteousness, going towards
technology, artificial intelligence,
they shall become one singular with this
world. Now, let's go back to Grock's new
logo of the singularity, which is a
picture of a black hole, and it also has
Saturn's symbolism with the ring. Now
what I find interesting about this image
depicting a black hole which reminds me
of revelation 9:11 and they had as a
king over them the angel of the
bottomless pit like a black hole whose
name in Hebrew is Abadin but in the
Greek he has the name Apolon. What I
found interesting in my studies about
this figure, Apollon or Abadin,
according to Derek Gilbert here, is that
this individual, this entity is Saturn.
As we can see right here from his
article, the rise of Apolon, that came
out in 2022, which is about his book,
The Return of Saturn, which I highly
recommend. He writes, I believe the
identity of Abadin and Apolon in
Revelation 911, the angel of the
bottomless pit is Saturn, the Watcher
Chief Shemiaza. The opening of the
bottomless pit marks his literal return
to Earth. It should be obvious by now
that the return of old Saturn's reign
will not bring the yearned for golden
age that's been dreamed of for more than
2,000 years. For those who do not know,
the golden age of Saturn goes back to
Greek and Roman mythology, which is also
Kronos in the Greek, which is a period
of peace and prosperity that appears in
again Roman and Greek literature. Hm,
that's strange. who is obsessed with
Greek mythology and the term golden age.
Oh yeah, that's right. Mr. Golden Dawn
himself proclaim that the golden age of
America is upon us. I'm sure it's just a
coincidence. So I for one find this very
interesting that the logo for Grock now
is the singularity which is a black hole
which shows Saturn symbolism literally
showing you that Saturn Abaden Apolon is
coming out of the bottomless pit. And I
guess it's just a coincidence that CERN,
the large Hadron collider that smashes
particles together at light speed,
trying to create black holes, has a
statue of Shiva, the god of destruction
with a portal around him. Again, as you
can see here in Hinduism, Shiva is known
as the destroyer of worlds. Just as we
know, Apolon, Abaden, or Saturn is known
as the destroyer. But now, let's go back
to CERN and how they are unveiling the
universe's secrets. a quantum leap with
AI at CERN. And how in this article we
can see the parallels between quantum AI
and CERN's cuttingedge research are
striking. Both delve into the strange
world of the subatomic seeking answers
to fundamental questions. So right here,
this idea of delving into the strange
world of the subatomic that is literally
going into a different dimension. And if
you continue reading in this article,
you will see how quantum AI offers the
potential to correct the mysteries of
the universe. As quantum AI and quantum
computing continue to evolve, we can
expect even more remarkable
breakthroughs at the intersection of
artificial intelligence and particle
physics. And I guess it's just a
coincidence that they use the name
Stargate for this new project or
operation where they are combining
artificial intelligence with something
else that you put inside your body.
Because the ultimate goal will be this
right here, the biodigital convergence
and the merging of biological and
digital technologies to create new
applications and technologies. So
basically merging man with artificial
intelligence. The the merge scenario
with AI is the one that
seems like probably the best. As you
just heard from the false prophet's
mouth, the best situation is to merge
with artificial intelligence. And go
figure again the name Grock means to
merge with. And what intelligence does
he want you to merge with? Saturn,
Abaden, Apolon, who comes out of the
bottomless pit. And this is why you will
see Saturn symbolism everywhere in this
world system. Also why you will see the
black cube everywhere because this also
symbolizes Saturn. I guess that's just a
coincidence right there. And does nobody
else find it interesting that at the 911
memorial site they have what appears to
be a cube bottomless pit? And again,
Revelation 911 is about the bottomless
pit and the king of the bottomless pit
which is Abaden, Apollon or Saturn.
Dude, what? That dude that's deep. But
that's Wow. He he he he basically
condenses it in a few minutes like
what's going on. Yeah. I actually did
not know what Grock meant. And uh when
he's talking about Revelation 911, I've
talked about 911, what that means. If
you guys want to watch a video called
the the deception is bigger than we
thought or something like that, it shows
Trump with a patch on his ear. But it it
breaks down what 911 means and how on
the side of Trump's hat he it's two
numbers that equal 911. I can't
remember. He's he was the something
president and now he's that president.
Those numbers equal 911. 45 48. Yeah.
Yeah. So four 4 + 7 is 11 and four plus
five is nine. Right. So Right. So he had
911 on his hat. And it's like this isn't
just
um a coincidence of some date that
happened with the Twin Towers. Like
there
was esoteric numerology, all that kind
of stuff tied into why it even happened
on 911. Why you keep seeing that happen
all the time? Revelation 911.
Um that's not the only reason seeing
that the black hole that that uh cube in
in uh you know like like a bottomless
pit kind of idea, right? Yeah. As he
said, that's crazy. And then his his own
cube on his tower. Revelation Revelation
911 is literally about like Satan
manifesting as Christ like him
manifesting in our world. And that
number just comes up all the time.
Crazy.
and and 911 is uh is what?
Um the alarm uh so I I'd have to go back
when I when I did that presentation it
was like God was opening my eyes to
things but I remember it was like nine
represented
um like um rebirth. It was kind of like
the the phoenix rising out of the ashes
and stuff. And the 11 was about these
towers literally two pillars which the
twin towers are built off that number 11
literally. And the whole thing is about
a rebirth bringing you into a new world
order into a new order is what it said.
And it said you have to either
physically or symbolically destroy those
two towers and then bring it back as
one. What literally happened at ground
zero? Two physical towers were brought
down and turned into one tower that was
called the new world tower. I mean, yes.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Or one world
tower. Next to Yeah. But but then next
next to it, you have that uh kind of
phoenix rising kind of symbol. I didn't
know that thing, right? Oh, I wish I
would have known that. It's kind of like
ah it's like that white um it's a mall
kind of but it has two wings and it's
kind of like a phoenix idea. It's what I
heard. It's like, man, that's crazy. I
didn't I didn't even know that. That
would have fit perfect. Wow, man. Yeah.
Should we go to the next slide here?
Yeah, next slide.
Oh, so here you see uh Trump uh on the
cover. Long live the king. Oh my
goodness. On the White House website,
right, of
the So, just so people know, it's not an
official magazine. It's kind of made to
look like Time magazine. Either Trump is
just like the biggest troll or this
stuff really does mean something and
they're putting it right in your
faces. But yeah, it's right there on the
White House Instagram photo. Man, long
live the
king. They really do act like he is a
king. Like they they act like now that
Trump's in, he can do whatever, man. He
can change the world.
Not just America basically last time we
talked about it like he he
he you know uh the apathosis right so he
became God right he's the god king so he
can do whatever he wants
basically and you see that and that's
that's what what he does and we go into
that he thinks that he can change
whatever he wants to crazy oh my
goodness what is
This is This is the US Homeland Security
News official website, right? It's the
official tick there.
That's crazy. Imperator Donald Trump,
right? Long live our empirator Donald
Trump. Savior of our
republic, dude. For homeland security.
And and isn't it funny that a republic
the whole republic is is a is a is a
Roman Roman idea. Did you know that? I
didn't know that. No. Yeah. The republic
the whole republic is a Roman idea. Wow.
And he's sitting there dressed in that
crimson like that.
Emperor.
Wow. This is getting like the things
that I found, man. It's it's crazy.
Twilight Zone, man.
an AF also
uh the federal agency for financial
oversight.
Yeah, he uh I mean he's he's
digitalizing everything and this is of
course going into the currency as well,
right? So So this is the US Homeland
Security's official uh X. What are they
saying?
Huh? They're saying that we should go
they should have a new currency or
something. No, no, no. Basically, that's
that's Elon Musk proposes uh uh the the
Federal Agency for Financial Oversight.
Uh basically that's the uh another
instead of do doge uh now also the an
arm of Doge basically because he's
cutting all those those uh those um
financial uh um how do you call it? Uh
he's um he's cutting cutting all these
uh he's he's how do the waste money as
they say. And this is this is the funny
part, right? Why why now? Why not right
in his four first term, right? Why all
of a sudden now cutting all these
things? He could have done it in the
first term. Why didn't he do that in the
first term? He knew that it was draining
the swamp, right? So why why not back
then? Because it's 2025. This is the
right timing. This is well but but you
did a video on on the United Nations and
and and Biden signing the pact with the
United Nations for AI governance, right?
That needed to be done first, right? And
now the groundwork is done. Now they can
Stargate came out and now they can do
all the the digitalization of everything
else. It's all building blocks, right?
So he couldn't do that possibly in the
first term, right? You see all these
planes going down. You see all these
things. Oh, we need AI. All everything
needs to be AI. Yeah. You can't trust
human pilots anymore. We need AI pilots.
No, same with cars. You know, car
crashes. Oh, well, self-driving cars. We
cannot trust. I mean, this has been
predicted in movies like Born Identity
and stuff. They get everybody's just in
cars and the cars are driving to work
and and that's the thing they're telling
us. You'll own nothing and be happy.
You're not going to have a vehicle
anymore. You're going to get in your
gray Tesla Cybert truck or whatever.
Everybody's going to have like Teslas.
You're not going to own it. It's the
state. It's like going to a library and
and borrowing a book. It's not yours.
You can use it for a while, but then you
got to take it back. So, uh in your
driveway there might be a car. Maybe
not. You might wake up, there's no car,
so you get on your app and the
self-driving car pulls up in your
driveway and takes you to work. When you
come when you're done at work, you're
not getting back in the same car. You're
getting in another car, you know. Um,
how safe is that going to be for people?
I I get the concept. It does sound
communism sounds good on the surface.
What were you saying, Minnow? Sorry. No,
I was saying I've seen enough movies.
This is iroot. I mean, Minority Report,
uh, you know, whatever those movies,
Eagle Eye,
uh, iRoot, um, I can name them all.
Yeah, I've seen them all. So, this thing
right here, I I don't know if this is
exactly what it was talking about, but I
I saw a clip of Elon in front of, you
know, on stage talking to somebody about
AI, and he was saying AI is going to
take a lot of jobs. And a lot of people
might laugh at that. That's it's not a
silly thing. People love to like look at
a bad AI video or a bad AI image and
laugh at it and say, "Oh, and this is
what they think's going to take over."
Today, right this moment, this is the
worst AI is ever going to be. In a
second, it's getting better. Every
second, it's evolving. It's getting
better every day. You can't laugh at it
and say, "It'll never take my job." If
you're a graphic designer, it's it's got
your job. If you're if you're a you
subtitle movies, it's got your job. If
you dub, you translate, if you're a Uber
driver, it's got your job. It can do
anything that you can do unless I don't
know, there's there's maybe some jobs
that are safe right now, but
realistically 40% of the jobs can be
taken over by AI. And so Elon Musk is
saying this is going to cause chaos.
This is going to cause an economic
collapse. We What do you do when 40% of
the population has no job? There's no
money. Everybody's starving. That that
causes chaos,
cannibalism. And he said, "We have to we
have to figure out solution for they
have a solution. They have a solution.
Universal basic income, right? Exactly.
That's exactly what I was talking about.
I thought I thought that might be what
this is basically everybody gets an
allowance because nobody has jobs
anymore. you get a government check in
the mail and the social credit score
will be perfect for that. If you don't
know what that is, they're doing it in
China right now. But basically, you got
to be a good citizen so that your app
will show that you got a good credit
score because if it goes below a certain
number because you littered
or whatever they deem a sinful thing,
well, now you can't travel because you
you try everything is, you know, scan my
QR code. Nope, it won't take it. Sorry,
your your social credit score is too
low. You got to go out and do some good
deeds. And one one of those good deeds
might be you got to go to the universal
church. You got to go to the one the one
world church and check in to get that
credit score up. AI AI church. AI
church. And and don't you dare be
reading the Bible or don't you dare be
like keeping the Sabbath or something
because that's
uh I don't know that's a sin somehow.
Yeah. Oh, man. So, yeah. I don't know
how if if they're mocking us or not,
right? But it's it's and this we've seen
this uh in the news. Uh they they you
know, everything gold and it's you saw
that in a video. Trump is all about
gold. Now he wants to see and they want
to go back to the gold standard, right?
They want to everything backed by gold
again, the golden age. Oh, I want to
check
the money uh is still if the gold is
still there. President Trump confirms
that he and Elon Musk will personally
audit Fort Knox gold reserve to ensure
that the 5,000 tons of gold is still
there for them.
What if it's not there? Are they going
to say, "Okay, well, we're going to
replace it with our money."
Yeah. I don't know. It's uh that's the
thing. Our money's our money is
worthless. It's it's if it's not backed
by gold, it means nothing. It's You
notice correct money. I have a I have an
old five or an old $1 bill and it's got
a blue seal on it and it says this is a
silver certificate. It says it's a
certificate and it says this is a silver
certificate backed up by silver, I
guess. But now you won't see that on a
dollar. A dollar says this is a Federal
Reserve note. M there's a big difference
in a certificate and a note. I mean, if
you go to college for 5 years and and
you get a note for it, that doesn't
really hold weight. You're trying to get
a certificate, right? I'll just write
you I'll just write you a note. Yeah,
let me just write you a note. Show this
to your next employer. Mikey, great job,
Mikey, for great. Yeah, good job. Yeah,
you got it. You get a job with it now,
right?
Wow, dude. That doesn't work that way.
Yeah, it's crazy.
So this is insane as well. Like so we
have all presidents that can the the the
maximum is two terms, right? Yeah. What
does Mr. Trump want to do? He's and
people are think that he is joking, but
he's absolutely not. And we're going to
see this.
Could we possibly see a third Trump
term? A new resolution put forth in the
House by a Tennessee Republican lawmaker
is seeking to allow current and future
presidents to run for a third term. The
resolution would amend the 22nd
amendment, which limits presidents to
two terms. An amendment to the
Constitution requires approval from
twothirds of both the House and the
Senate. While President Trump was in
South Florida at a House GOP conference,
he joked about running for a third term.
I've raised a lot of money for the next
race that I assume I can't use for
myself, but I'm not 100% sure because
I don't know. I think I'm not allowed to
run again. I'm not sure. Am I allowed to
run again, Mike? I better not get you
involved in that argument.
Oh my goodness. So,
uh, yeah. So, he's
he's either playing ignorant. He's
joking about it.
He's joking about it. He's How can you
be so ignorant as a president, right?
He's not stupid. He's just pushing the
envelope. He's just He's just pushing it
out there. see how people uh react to
it, right? And then he's pushing there.
Then he's pushing again there and then
he's making it work. Then he's m then
he's having people making a law about uh
or you know putting a bill together and
and and present it right. So it's crazy,
but it's interesting because I'm I'm
thinking like, okay, so if he 2028,
right, is the next next cycle, right? I
know that the N the new apostolic
reformation, they have uh empower 21,
it's called, and they have the vision
that by
2033, everyone on earth will have have
an encounter with Jesus Christ. Oh my.
They said, um, is that what our Bible
tells us? No. 2023. Well, the only
that's what they what they say by 2023,
they want everyone to have encounter
with Jesus Christ. Well, yeah, we're
2025. So, if he's in the next term and
all these Christians that are in that
Empire 21, that's the Kenneth Copelins
and all these N people, new Apostolic
Reformation people,
right? They they and it's also uh 33,
right? And uh Jesus was 33 and yeah,
they think that Jesus went to heaven
when he was 33 or so something like that
and that he then comes back after 2,000
years. So there's a whole thing behind
it, right? But what if the false messiah
is coming back at that moment, right? Is
or perfect setup. Oh my goodness. It's
it's a perfect setup. And if he's in in
if he is in in uh in in office, he can
make it all happen, right? He's the best
friend of the of all the Christians
right now. Wow. Okay. I I want to
clarify what I said. I thought you said
2023. You're saying 2033. No, 2033.
Yeah. Yeah. That is super masonic. And
uh but it makes sense because people
think, yeah, Jesus came back at the year
of his death, the age of his death or
whatever.
Wow, dude. So deceptive.
Yeah. And our next video is also about
the the the you see here Mr. uh fans
talk about uh about it as well. Well, we
also know that he's kind of dropped
hints. Maybe a third term is possible.
Maggie Haberman in the Times wrote this
about those comments. In private, Mr.
Trump has told advisers that it is just
one of his myriad diversions to grab
attention and aggravate Democrats,
according to people familiar with his
comments when he says something about a
third term. The third term gambit could
also serve another purpose. Political
observers noted keeping congressional
Republicans in line as Mr. Trump pushes
a maximalist version of executive
authority with the clock ticking on his
time in office. Does that sound
plausible? I don't think Donald Trump is
ever joking. It's true with Panama
Canal. It's true with Gaza. It's true
with Greenland. It's true with
everything he does. We spoke in the last
segment about a constitutional crisis.
If Donald Trump thinks he will ascend to
a third term, we've moved from a
constitutional crisis to a
constitutional collapse. Truly, get your
passports ready. Because if that is what
Donald Trump thinks he is capable of
doing and if the courts were to suggest
that somehow that is a valid option for
this president and if Republicans in
Congress suggest it as well, it's the
end of the constitutional democracy that
we currently appreciate and have. I
don't think it's a joke that Donald
Trump entertains those ideas. I think
what he does is he plants the seed
knowing he has a runway in this case of
about four years to build the case and
let's see what happens. That's what he
does. He throws out this wild idea. He
tries to mainstream it and then let's
see how it develops. It is a
constitutional collapse if Donald Trump
and the courts and Republicans suggest
he's eligible for a third Oh my
goodness, dude. Yeah. And what's funny?
Testing the waters. Yeah. Yeah. What
what's crazy actually is
that his
followers, they're like idol
worshippers, man. They like idolize this
dude and they'd be all about this.
Actually, they're they're probably
already They think it's a great idea,
huh? They think it's a fantastic idea.
Yeah. I mean, Trump's our king. 40 extra
years. Oh my goodness,
dude. Well, yeah. Right there. There you
have it. And Third Term Project.
So, there's actually a group of people
out there that have started this
organization, ThirdTerm Project for
Trump 2028 and beyond. They Oh, yeah.
Not just a third term and beyond.
[Laughter]
Oh, it's it's crazy. Yeah, this is also
a video. Um, but yeah, this is nuts,
man. What's going on with I know Elon
did that Nazi salute. Who's the guy
above? Oh, that's uh Bannon, Steve
Bannon. Oh, you you see how much I know
about politics.
Yeah, he was in Trump's uh in Trump's
um uh or cabinet, I think, uh in the the
first um first for the first term. Oh,
okay. And he was from Breitbart uh I
believe. Oh, but I mean al also
Catholic.
Yeah. No wonder if I had Yeah, man. You
got to have those Catholics on the
board,
man. So, this is this is interesting
though because it says third term
project, which it's got that eagle and
it just it looks 28 and beyond. Yeah, it
looks so Nazi already. I'm thinking
third Reich, you know, Third Reich. You
got this, they're doing the Nazi salute,
you got the the eagle, all that is Nazi
right there. And then you got Trump
looking like Caesar. Yeah. Who who is
Caesar? Caesar is a Roman, right?
All roads lead to Rome. Bible prophecy
says that America is going to become a
mirror image of the beast which is Rome.
We are literally taking form of Rome
right now. It's crazy. Yeah. Oh. Uh Bo.
Yeah. And we're we're going to see that
uh basically this is already copy of
Rome, but it's it's becoming more and
more visible, right? Yep. Exactly.
My videos, you will know that I This is
a video. I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah,
it's video. Okay, let's play it. Now, if
you've been following my videos, you
will know that I have talked about the
Roman Empire and how it has never it
never went away. It's secretly been in
power in every government of the world
under many different guises. It's
basically the beast right now. We must
remember this is the enemy revealing
itself. It's always been there. The
spirit of antichrist as it states in
scripture has been there from the
beginning. Hence why the Roman Empire,
it never went away. It is the beast and
it's always been there under many
different guises and many different
names and many different organizations.
but it very rarely reveals what it
really is. It's been pretending to be
something that it wasn't. It's been
putting on a front. The idea of the big
reveal now is that if we are heading
towards the end times, it will need to
start to show itself as what it really
is. As it has to do this in the end
times because it wants the people of the
earth to see what it really is. so that
they can choose to accept it or not. So
that when those that accept it and
follow it do so, they are doing it with
full knowledge of what it is. Hence why
these things will come more and more
into the spotlight. This is why you are
seeing this all going on in America. Why
recently Elon Musk was doing the fascist
salute which has now been echoed by
Steve Bannon at CPAC recently. This is
the normalizing of it. This is the
beginning of causing the inhabitants of
the earth to worship the beast. Of
course, we've seen things like this
happened before in the past in history,
but they were isolated and you didn't
have the power of the internet, social
media, the influence and connectivity
that that has across the world. And this
is the USA, which is the most dominant
economic and military power of all
countries, which doesn't really matter
anyway because all of those countries
are linked through the United Nations,
which of course is also the Roman
Empire. So, here we have some recent
images I thought were interesting from
the CPAC, uh, which is a MAGA proTrump
conservative convention.
There's loads of images of Musk who was
at it with a chainsaw for whatever
reason, but it's this Steve Bannon who
like Musk recently, he snuck in the
fascist beast system salute. As you can
see here, of course, the false prophet
media, they tried to focus this on it
being a Nazi salute, but it is a Roman
salute. Hitler did it. That was yet in
another formulation of the beast which
was probably a trial run for now when
it's going to be done by the USA. And
now we are seeing the normalization of
this. This is the same Steve Bannon who
just before Trump won the election said
that if Trump wins they will enact rough
Roman justice. I have the clip in an old
video. Uh, for the life of me, I can't
remember which video it was, but yeah,
he said if they win the election that
Trump is a kind man, but we ain't like
him. When we get in, we're not kind. We
will get revenge on all those who
disagree with us and we will enact rough
Roman justice. And what is rough Roman
justice? Well, that would be severe
military Roman Empire justice. And that
would be executions, torture. Yeah. Or
crucifixion. Yeah. So we are seeing a
clear pattern here in the clip where
Bannon gives the salute. He doesn't even
hide it. I mean if you if you watch it,
he even implies in a way that he says
yeah I just did that. Deal with it. Of
course he also says fight fight fight as
he gives the salute. Musk of course did
this recently. This is the same musk
that talks about how he thinks about the
Roman Empire every day in the new world
order. So what we are seeing here is the
beast revealing itself so that the
followers of it are under no mistake
what it is if they choose to follow it.
This is the power structures of the
world slowly revealing who and what they
really are and what they have always
been. Also, we have at this CPAC this
interesting poster where once again uh
this goes in alignment with what I
mentioned in earlier videos. Here we see
this poster for Trump. He's drawn like a
Roman Empire emperor style imagery. As
you can see above his head, we have the
eagle, a symbol for the Roman Empire,
and it says thirdterm project for Trump
2028. and beyond. Yeah. So, of course,
an American president can only be
president for two terms, two times, and
then he has to step down. So, a total of
about 8 years. But here we see some
movement to stop this law and make it
possible for Trump to stay as president
for a third term. Like an emperor. An
emperor can rule more than one country
as well. Also, he's there until he
clanks it. And so this poster you can
see is clearly hinting at that. Now you
remember again I pointed it out in an
earlier video last year how Trump said
before the last election he addressed
Christians specifically at a rally
saying please vote for me just this one
time. You only have to vote for me once.
He said and you'll never have to vote
again. hinting at this exact thing that
he wasn't going anywhere after he got
in. He was going to stay there. And all
of this is the beast slowly revealing
itself to the world. And of course, it
also wants to be popular. It wants the
people of the earth to like it. It wants
to normalize its ways. It wants the
people of the earth to follow the beast.
So, as you can see, we have, you know,
in the news now, we've got these
scenarios in the false prophet news.
We've got these scenarios where Trump
and people like Musk are being set up as
heroes, as people who are changing
things for the better. How Trump is
going to bring peace in the Middle East
and Russia and Ukraine. How Musk is
weeding out all the corruption in in
government, etc., etc. These are your
counterfeit saviors, counterfeit kings,
counterfeit emperors, kings, counterfeit
to the King of Kings, who is Jesus.
Dude, that guy nailed it.
I um a friend of mine who's been on here
before, Josh, he made a whole video
talking about that salute was a Roman
salute, and I forgot I knew it went
further than um than the Nazis, but I
couldn't remember who it was associated
with. And when he said that about the
Roman salute, I was so glad he added
that because this is the thing. God
can't be fair if if he doesn't allow
everything to come out. And right now,
everything's so in your face. All of
entertainment, all the entertainment
industry, you know, the P. Diddy files,
the Nickelodeon stuff, uh they're just
any anyone who performs now is literally
doing a satanic ritual right in front of
you. Everything's witchcraft and it's so
in your face. And now with the Nazi
salutes and the Rome stuff right in your
face, when Christ returns, nobody's
going to have an excuse. Nobody can say
like, "I couldn't tell. I didn't know."
Dude, it says that all things will be
revealed. That's where we're at right
now. Everything in secret is coming out
into the open, whether it's Diddy Files
or Nickelodeon or whatever. And people
can ignore it and stay ignorant, but
that's not going to save them in the
end. God is saying, "Come out of her, my
people." And it's making it so
clear. He's pleading with you. Come out.
And that we have to I mean, time is time
is short. I don't think people realize
how soon Christ is coming. Not only
that, but how it will inform what you
participate in. like you're saying, you
will not go to these concerts because
they're all basically witchcraft
performed in front of you. You probably
should stop watching TV
um and so on. Like just don't give into
their propaganda and brainwashing. Like
it seriously will screw you up and make
things harder to be right with God
before he comes. It's Satan's devices.
The Bible says, "Let us not be ignorant
of Satan's devices." They literally call
them devices now. I mean, it was in the
Bible. And Satan's using these devices
to push his merchandise. It talks about
in Ezekiel, he's pushing his merchandise
and deceiving the world uh through
pharmarmacia or sorcery. We look at that
word in in the Bible it says sorcery in
English, but in the Greek it's
pharmarmacia. And we think automatically
like drugs. Well, maybe I'm not on
drugs. But it's anything that medicates
the mind. Correct. If you
are if you're escaping through TV all
day or your phone all day, that's
medicating your mind as well. It's not
being sober like the Bible God calls us
to be. Scientifically, they say the the
brain of a porn addict is just like a
cocaine addict. You don't even have it's
not the physical drug that's doing the
brain damage. It's the the addiction,
the dopamine hits, all that stuff. A
porn addict has the same brain on a on a
scan. Like they can look at it and say,
"You have the same brain as a cocaine
addict." Interesting. Anything that
medicates the mind is pharmarmacia. And
that's how Satan's going to deceive the
whole world through sorcery.
Sorcery. Hollywood. The the wood of
Holly. The the wizard's wand. Yeah.
Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah. I mean,
yeah,
dude. This is good stuff, man.
Yeah. So, um, the the next slide, what
what do we have there? Oh, yeah. That's
the video. Oh, yeah. This is super open.
That's new for me. I haven't seen this
one. You add it up. Let's check it out.
Through your leadership, you embody the
values of our Christian faith and love
for the gospel.
Really, you remind me of the great Roman
emperor, Constantine the Great.
Constantine the Great.
Wow.
I just I don't want to replay that.
This great Roman Emperor Constantine the
Great.
They're cheering.
This
emperor, this emperor, your dear Mr.
President is the one who founded and
built the magnificent city of
Constantinople, my birthplace. Wow. No.
Why are they chair of that? Known today
as Istanbul. It is my great honor to
present you with this holy cross.
Wow. Thank you. This cross is the very
symbol that led this great Roman Emperor
Constantine to victory.
As Christ revealed to him in a vision,
he said, "And Tutoto Nika told the
emperor means go with this and be
victorious." Mr.
President, this cross is an everlasting
symbol of peace and an invincible
trophy, a sign of divine strength and
guidance. With this cross, I pray you
bring peace to the world and make
America invincible.
Wow. Look at these idol worshippers.
[Applause]
Dude, that is insane. Unbelievable. Hold
on. So when
Constantine followed the cross and he
had his vision and wanted to declare the
day of the sun, it was the UN, he said,
"Make us um invincible," I think to
Trump. Something like that. And
Constantine didn't use those words, but
it was the unconquerable sun god that he
was actually giving credence to and
declaring as his god at that
point. Yeah. I mean, this is this is so
messed up on every level. For one,
calling Trump Constantine, there you go
again with Rome. You're literally
connecting him back to Rome again. And
everybody cheering just shows how
deceived everybody is. And then he's
giving him this cross relic. This could
be a controversial topic. There's no
power in a symbol of a cross. It it is a
symbol. It is it is a memorial of what
Christ did for us. But to to hold that
thing and act like there's some kind of
power in it, that's that's a relic.
That's an idol in itself. There's no
power in that cross that he just gave
Trump. And like she just said, he saw
that cross on the sun and he went to go
make
war to bring about a false Christianity.
The whole thing that Constantine did was
enforce worship on Sunday and force
Christians that he was killing to go to
church on Sunday and do not keep the
Sabbath because that's Judaizing and
Judaizers will be killed. Mhm. But you
can go to church on Sunday. You can use
our temples with all these idols. Oh,
that's not really Saturn and Mercury.
That's Peter and Paul. It
you can't baptize Christianity and think
it's okay. That's that's exactly what's
wrong with Catholicism.
There's many there's many well-meaning
Christians that are in there that are
just deceived. But the whole system is
created on false system of worship.
Yeah. Wow. I had not seen that video. I
I was about to and I know that some
people already made a video about him or
about it. And uh I had no time the last
few days to to really uh get into that.
But that's Wow. That's another this
comment that just came in. Word ministry
says Constantine made the first day the
first Sunday law. So it's fitting dude.
I mean think about that. We're This is
Wow. Yeah. Project 2025. What is that?
It's to make Wow. Trump have the ability
to create religious laws. So, they've
already set up the groundwork that
project 2025. Trump Trump won. Now,
Project 25 is in. Now, they're calling
him Constantine. They're literally
putting in your face that history's
repeating itself. Mhm.
Wow. This is Constantine is where all
this started in the first place with the
ecumenical church. Yeah. Oh, absolutely.
Yeah. And Sunday worship and and
everything. There's a there's a lot of
people out there that don't believe in
Sunday law. And I get it. They think it
it's a a chip in the hand or whatever.
Um, but regardless of technology that's
that will be used to enforce the mark of
the beast, because I'll tell you right
now, the mark of the beast is not
technology. It the technology is how
they enforce the mark of the beast. It's
how they punish you if you don't worship
that this way. They get hung up on where
it says if you don't take the mark, you
can't buy and sell. And they're like,
boom, there it is. It's a microchip. No.
If you don't worship according to the
law, you're not going to be able to buy
and sell. Also, you're going to be
thrown in prison 10 days and also you're
going to be beheaded.
Well, I would I would I would argue this
way like what if you go into surgery and
they put a put it in in your just put it
in you while while you're under surgery.
You can't help it, right? So, oh, now
all of a sudden you have to mark the
beast. Yeah. At birth when they take
your kid away. Oh, yeah. You know, the
nurses know what they're doing and they
chip the your baby. Now, your baby has
had his free will taken away. That's why
a microchip cannot be the mark of the
beast because it takes away free will.
All the Christians are conscious choice
that you make. It's a conscious choice
and you know what choice you're making.
Yes. If because I I I think that that
that it needs to be a fair choice. Yes.
And we know in the end times it's not
your choice either, right? According to
the Bible, he's going to have power to
overcome the saints and he's going to
imprison them and all that stuff. And if
they decide to microchip you like
cattle, then man has the power to pluck
you from God's hand. All these people
that say that uh once saved always saved
because Satan can't pluck you out of his
hand and all that stuff. I don't believe
once saved always saved. I believe that
salvation is a relationship and you have
to keep that relationship. You have to
build that relationship. And God gives
you the freedom to walk away. Like the
prodical son, he walked away from the
father. But when he returned to the
father, the father said, "My son was
dead. Now he's alive. He was lost. Now
he's found. Those are all sign those are
all um terms for being unsaved. The kid
who was the father of or the son of the
father was unsaved when he walked away.
But when he returned the father open
openly embraced him. Now the same people
who say once saved always saved think
you can have your salvation removed by
man if you get a microchip in you. Well,
but but but I would argue and and I've
believed in that too. But if you think
about it, like if that's the case, then
why are all the Jews not not saved?
Because if if it's once saved, always
saved and faith was before Christ and
after Christ, it's by faith. Oh, gotcha.
Yeah, that's a good point. Well, why are
they not saved? There are some people
that think all Jews are going to be
saved somehow. I don't know. The very
ones that crucified Christ and reject
him to this day, they're somehow they're
God's chosen people still and they're
going to be saved. I
man, Satan has done an amazing job at
twisting everything in in the mainstream
Christianity right now.
Correct. Correct. What do we have next?
Oh, what is this? Uh Trump is Oh, yeah.
Trump says he's not joking about
potentially running for a third term.
Fox News. There you go. just pulling a
Roosevelt. Okay, I'm not joking.
Oh, and this and so this video is uh the
same guy that we just saw, not uh your
video, but the before that Rome never
went away. He referred to that video.
Yeah, this is basically that video.
Okay. Uh and again, all roads lead to
Rome. Yeah. Wow. Let's check it out. So,
all roads lead to Rome. We'll start with
Roman symbols and their predominance all
across the world. I touched on this
recently with the double-headed eagle.
We'll get on to that in a moment, but
first let's take a look at this one.
This is called the fascis. It's an
assemblage. It's a weapon, right? It's
an assemblage of wooden rods bound
together, typically about a meter and a
half long, bound by leather straps
together with a single headed axe.
Sometimes there's a double-headed axe.
And this is a symbol from ancient Rome.
It was a weapon used to oppress people.
It was carried by licers who were Roman
civil servants, bodyguards to
magistrates. And they were used to
oppress and execute people who would not
submit to the will of the Roman Empire.
They were used to fogg and decapitate
people basically. Now, this symbol of
the fascist can be found all over the
place. Here we see it at the US House of
Representatives
on either side of the USA flag, either
side of where the speakers perform and
talk. If you recall the House of
Representatives, they put through the
COVID bill. It had the number of HR
666. Yes. Anyway, you may ask, why are
these ancient Roman symbols of
oppression, the fascists, up there on
either side? Oh, and uh, by the way,
this is where the word fascist, fascism,
comes from. It comes from the weapon,
the fascist and the symbol. So, why are
these ancient Roman symbols in the USA
House of
Representatives? Fascist weapons.
Fascism meaning a way of organizing a
society in which a government ruled by a
dictator controls the lives of the
people and in which people are not
allowed to disagree with the government
which is kind of what we have is it not
they have created an illusion of
democracy through the media when in
actual fact it's an autocracy
which they want to now take to a new
level with a one world government as
stated in prophecy. Now, back to the
USA. One of the reasons for these Roman
symbols in the House of Representatives,
it says here, is they say the founding
fathers used Rome as an inspiration. Of
course, the founding fathers were
Freemasons. You'll also notice they have
a reef around the fascists, like the
Roman laurel reef, which is also you see
it elsewhere at the House of
Representatives here, for example.
There's loads more. You have one at the
president's oval office, a fascist above
the door. We also see the eagle is on
top of the fascist mace they use at the
House of Representatives. The mace being
a symbol of authority, a ceremonial
staff like they use elsewhere in the UK
House of Commons in New Zealand, etc.
They also have a symbol of the eagle in
the ceiling. Now, take note of these
ancient Roman symbols, specifically the
fascist, the eagle, and the laurel reef.
This is the same laurel reef you see
around the United Nations logo. Again,
ancient Rome. The laurel reef were and
are symbols of military victory of Roman
military commanders or emperors who wore
them in battle. Why do you think the
United Nations uses an ancient Roman
laurel reef surrounding what looks like
a circle flat earth map? Roman victory
over all of the nations just as the
World Health Organization also have the
Laurel Reef on its logo. And then of
course UNICEF also use the Laurel Reef.
All of these international organizations
using ancient Roman symbology. The eagle
is a symbol of Rome. It's been used over
and over. They also used the
doubleheaded eagle which was used by the
Baantine Empire which was the Eastern
Roman Empire and the Holy Roman Empire
which were the continuation of the
empire after Rome fell. And the
double-headed eagle represented an
augmentation of the Roman single eagle.
As we can see here, the single eagle. We
can also see this in use by the Nazis.
You see it here at the top of these
things. They are holding at one of their
marches. It was used by Mussolini. Here
we see an eagle holding the actual
fascists holding it with its claws. So
you've got two Roman symbols in one. The
same fascist weapon symbol from ancient
Rome that you saw at the House of
Representatives.
Oh, by the way, did you know that
Mussolini was also an MI5 British
intelligence agent? That's something to
look into. They're all in the club.
Germany uses the eagle. Russia uses the
double-headed eagle. All symbols linking
back to the Roman Empire, the same Roman
Empire that crucified Jesus after the
Jews asked them to. You will find these
symbols on buildings everywhere. The
Roman fascist decapitation weapons, say
here in Nottingham in the UK, or in
Paris, France, or in Germany. You'll see
the double-headed eagle in the UK as
here in the royal uh family, the Queen's
first draon guards on the reverse of
this Queen Victoria coin. loads of coins
all over the world with royalty from
different times featuring the eagle and
the double-headed eagle and laurel reefs
of course. Uh in the UK you have
Britannia which is supposedly the
national personification of Britain but
of course she's wearing a Roman helmet
and carrying a trident. Roman rule over
Britain ended over 1,500 years ago. So
history books tell us. Yet they still
keep these symbols. The Knights Templar
were a Roman Catholic military order and
the establishment in the UK royal family
are all in that club. They wear the
cross, the Knights of Malta. Just look
at them. Look at what they wear and
their connections to Freemasonry. Again,
very obvious, very clear. All in the
club. Talking of clubs, we have the Club
of Rome. No Roman symbols in their logo,
just a big old globe. They don't need
the symbols. They've got the the word
Rome in the title. The Club of Rome, it
says here, is a nonprofit informal
organization of intellectuals and
business leaders whose goal is critical
discussion of pressing global issues.
And they are the organization that
really started pushing the CC33 agenda
back in
1972 with their limits to growth report,
another offshoot of the United Nations.
And this agenda is now being used to
control the masses. Okay. On old Roman
coins, the trident appeared on the coins
when an eagle wasn't being displayed.
And of course, we have Ukraine with the
trident symbology now. And they are
working very closely with the USA and
the UK and the EU. Ukraine which was
once called Kazeria and the
Khazars who teamed up with the Bisantine
Empire who were the Eastern Roman
Empire. An alliance with Rome which
first began it says here in the early
7th century fighting together in wars.
Yeah. Khazars at some point also
converted to Judaism.
Then we have the Freemasons who use
double-headed eagles, especially in
regards to the Scottish right, Albert
Pike and so on. All of this is Roman
symbology, but you'll be told, you know,
the Roman Empire or the Roman dynasty,
it don't exist anymore. Yeah, maybe
they've changed their brand name, but
it's just using the same symbols. The
Roman Empire would be labeled today as a
fascist empire. That being an
authoritarian,
ultra-istic political ideology and
movement, usually with a dictator and no
form of democracy, usually attributed to
an individual country and leader. But
what if it was a one world government?
Does this sound like something that
might be happening at the moment? Yeah.
Is that the end of the clip? Dude, he's
spot. Hey, this dude is spot on, man.
Yeah, he is. Well, when he said
something about um I don't remember what
he said. Some something he said made me
think of these
religious what is it called? The
um the people that are doing the
national the the nationalist people. The
Christian nationalist.
something he said made me think of all
these people that are signing up for
that Christian nationalism. They are
literally the soldiers of Rome because
there's nothing about Christianity that
yeah you can't force Christianity that
is not Christian anymore once you force
Christianity it no longer becomes
Christian it becomes
Romanism
Catholicism and so you have all
these well-meaning people that just want
the the country to come back to God and
all that they get on board with this
Christian nationalism and they've really
just signed up to become Roman soldiers.
Yeah, it's crazy, dude. Well, and and
and and remember the Bible also says
like if uh um uh that that they uh they
think they do God a service, you know,
to to be to be that soldier and kill
Christians. Yeah. Just like Paul. Paul
was killing Christians in the name of
God. He believed in God. Yeah. That's
why when he got knocked off his horse,
he said, "Why are you persecuting me?"
And he was like, I thought I was working
for you. Working for you? Yeah. Yeah.
Wow, dude.
This is deep stuff, dude. Um, shout out
who who is this channel? Who is that
guy?
Oh, that Oh, that um who who Yugo talks.
Yugo talks. You can look it up on Yugo
Talks. H U G O and then talks. T A K.
That's what I say. You go talk. He's on
on um Rumble. He's on on YouTube. He's
on Oh, there it is. You see it? Yeah. Go
up up further. You
where up here? Keep passing it. Oh,
okay. Sorry. I'm trying to show it on
screen here. This is the actual channel
that Okay. It's right in there. So, if
you see it down there, it's Hugo Talks
on YouTube and Rumble. Awesome. Yeah,
definitely want to give that dude a
shout out, man. I'm going to check his
channel out.
Yeah, he's and and again, he he um he's
not always with everything. I agree. But
uh he he does his research. He does
absolutely
um uh dig deep. Yeah. Is this another
video by him? Yep. Yep. This is part
two. Uh the the the I mean it's a
lengthy video. I cut it all. um to make
it more condensed, but at least show
showing some of the things that we're
talking about today. Cool. Now, you
remember I did a video a while back
called All Roads Lead to Rome, which
speculated that the Roman Empire, it
never went away. That it's still the
same system in place today. They've just
changed their names. They've branched
out. They've created different versions,
monopolized it some more. how the UN,
the United Nations, the World Health
Organization, the Club of Rome, the EU,
the World Bank, all of these
organizations have Roman symbolism, the
double-headed eagle, the eagle, the
fascist symbol, royalty, and so on and
on. That is the system in control
everywhere. They are all linked. The
Roman Catholic Church, the Protestant
Church of England, your Cabala,
Freemasonic Societies. Yeah, they are
all worshiping pagan gods just like the
Roman Empire used to, but now they do it
under the disguise of the pretend
worship of God, right? Which is what we
saw on Saturday at the coronation. The
Roman Empire is still the ruling dynasty
and the Vatican state, the Rothschild
banking dynasty, the order of Malta, the
crown, the temple bar law system, the
Rosacruians, the Jesuits, the order of
the garter, the US Senate, you name it.
The ruling dynasty is the Roman Empire
and it's anti- good and it's anti-Jesus.
Always has been. There's so much. Maybe
I'll stick the all roads lead to Rome
video at the end of this because I
haven't got the time to rego over all of
that again. Now, so look, the
coronation, it was full of Roman Empire
imagery and symbolism. Let's start with
the Penny Mant who stuck out like a sore
thumb. Uh the politician, she was up for
being prime minister with Rishi Sunnac,
but she didn't win. carrying some sword
in the ceremony in this blue dress which
had Roman laurels all all over it. The
dress apparently it says here is called
the Poseidon midi dress. Right. Poseidon
is Neptune. Neptune is a Roman god of
the sea. You'll see more of that in a
second. Some have suggested it looks a
bit like Poundland. Yeah, Poundland is
also part of the Roman Empire. Penny
Mortyn is establishment through and
through. Uh big army family. Uh she's
linked to Angela Lansbury, the actress.
Unusually, she was also a magician's
assistant once for a magician who was
quite a high up magician. He was the
president of one of the biggest magic
circles in the UK. And now now she's
involved in ceremonies and rituals where
at one point they had to bring in a
screen so you couldn't see what was
happening. just like they do with the
magicians. The magician's assistant, you
know, would bring out the screen and
cover something and hey presto, the
thing is gone. So, she's clearly got the
Roman laurel all over the dress. Some
people will say, "Oh, it's it's based on
the Privy Council outfits." Yeah. Well,
that's also based on the Roman Empire
Laurel. Here we see the Kate Middleton
and her child, right, with the Roman
laurels on their heads. Again, it's kind
of telling you straight up. I mean, how
much how much imagery do you want to
see? People will say things like, you
know, what why is the entertainment
industry why does it seem so satanic?
Why does it promote all of these ungodly
evil things? Why is this this person
dressing up in this way and so on and so
forth? Why? What's with all the satanic
imagery? It's because the Roman Empire
is the ruling dynasty over the world.
The Roman Empire worshiped pagan gods.
This is the same imagery you see in the
films like the Hunger Games. Nothing's
changed. I mean, I know they're movies,
but they are telling you what's going on
in these movies. Nothing has changed
apart from the Roman Empire used to
worship pagan gods in public. Now, they
hide behind God and the Bible. They are
pretending to be Christians. I mean,
come on. I mean, you judge a tree by the
fruit it gives, right? I mean, how
stupid can you be? I mean, you're
watching Charles saying, "I swear to
serve and not to be served. I shall
serve you. I will not be served." And
then the next thing he's being ridden
out of a church in a multi-million pound
golden carriage with idiots in the rain,
poor people, peasants waving flags with
he's got a crown on his head in a golden
carriage full of je a crown full of
jewels stolen from other countries.
going home to where he has hundreds of
servants who will wait upon him and
serve him every minute of the day today,
tomorrow, and so on. I mean, are people
dafted? I mean, they're lying straight
to your straight to your face. I am not
here to be served. I'm here to serve
you. No. No, I don't think you are. They
are all connected with one another. And
it's the Roman Empire. All right.
Talking of the golden carriage, here we
see on the carriage the fascist symbol,
the Roman Empire weapon symbol. Same
symbol you see in the US House of
Representatives that the eagle holds.
Again, you'll see it in the video coming
up after this. Here it is on a corner of
the golden carriage. And here we see two
Poseidons or Neptunes holding the
fascists at the back of the carriage. M
Neptune of course is a Roman god, the
Roman god of the sea. And that brings us
back to the admirality law, the maritime
law of the sea. The king also being the
Leviathan. I mentioned that before. The
sea beast. Yeah. How he is not subject
to law. The king is not subject to law.
He is not subject to be prosecuted. He
doesn't need a passport. Neither does
the pope. They are two cheeks of the
same ass. Remember the king is a
personification of the state. He's a
personification. You're a person. He's
not a person, right? You're a person
because you are subject to law. He is
the personification of the state. He is
not subject to law. I talked about this
in the birth certificate video. You'll
have to go back and check that one out
at
hugoalks.com. The king is not subject to
law, but you are.
What? Oh, that is so in your face, man.
I Yeah, I can't remember where I saw a
video about that fascist thing, the the
big fat axe or whatever. He told us
about it in his last video. Yeah. Oh,
dude, that thing I can't believe it's
just everywhere.
It's everywhere. And we we're going to
go into that later uh also in this
video. But but also uh that um the the I
mean he's he's
funny uh but uh the the the the golden
carriers, right? I mean I'm here to
serve you. I'm like really?
Wow.
Uh it makes me think of but also the
fascist on them. Yeah. Mhm. It makes me
think of the um the artist that all he
did was he painted a picture of the pope
being carried out in that carriage and a
and a picture of Christ riding a humble
donkey. And he was showing this is the
difference. What What does it mean to be
a Christian? One who follows Christ. You
want to be like Christ. He's your Lord
and Master. You you do what he does.
Yeah. And then here's the pope with this
pump and people are carrying him uh in
this carriage or whatever and it's just
vastly different. And it was such a
powerful thing because a picture paints
a thousand words. All all this artist
did. Art is a powerful tool. I mean
that's why Satan loves to use it for
propaganda. But it's it's such a
powerful tool in making a statement,
making a point. That's why memes are so
powerful, too.
Absolutely.
Yeah. And and uh and and that's what I
what I've also uh done is like uh like
you know it's in video and we talked
about it in past shows but really show
it to you like hey this is this is what
you find. This is what I get it from the
from their own websites. Yes I used also
Wikipedia but also I used the
government's own websites like we did
last time. Right. So showing the showing
you from it's it's it's it's for real.
Well, I mean you cannot fake it like in
a house of representatives, right? I
mean fascist. It's insane.
So here it is. Yes. I mean here you see
see what what it means. The the fascist
insignia official authority in ancient
Rome. Um
wow dude.
So and here you see uh like uh the Roman
emperors beginning with Augustus in 19
BC BCE uh had 12 fascists but after
Domissionian reigned 81 to 96. Uh they
had 24 uh dictators 24 consils tw 12
pers six legates five priests one
lowering of the fascist was was a form
of salute to a higher official.
So bonito Mussolini uh his fascist party
of Italy was named for the fascist uh
which um the members adopted in 1919 as
their emblem. The winged libert liberty
dime minted in the United States from
1996 to 1945 depicts the fascist on its
reverse side. So it's is everywhere.
Yeah, dude.
This is so again dictionary right to
show you it's in uh the Miriam
dictionary. a bundle of rods and among
them an axe with projecting blade born
before ancient Roman ma magistrates as a
badge of authority.
Here you see it again. This is
Wikipedia. The fascist the fascist is an
Italian symbol Rome, right? Italian that
had its origin in Atruscan civilization
and was passed on to ancient Rome where
it symbolized a Roman king's power to
punish his subjects and later a
magistrate's power and and
jurisdiction and below it says and it
was the origin of the name of the
national fascist party in Italy from
which the term fascism is derived. The
guy Hugo was just saying that, right?
And it's it it's not just sucked out of
his thumb. It's it's it's real.
Some people say it's used also by Adolf
Hitler, by the way.
Some people said you got to echo. I hope
maybe I changed the microphone setting.
Maybe that'll help.
Oh, there it is. Here's the coin. Yep.
Here you got it.
Well, this is a the dollar. So, it's a
dollar. Uh, but the dime is on the
right. Yep.
Wow, dude. Wait, this is uh is it a
Roman coin or what is that? Oh, this is
also 1989. Okay. 1989 Congress bicential
dollar. Yeah, there are coins in the US.
This two US coins. It says United
States. Oh, yeah. Right there, man.
Wow.
And here's the US court's administrative
office seal on the left side.
And on the right side, you got uh uh
it's I think it's Washington, right? Or
Lincoln. Lincoln. Yeah. And then on on
on the on the on the pillar there, you
see the the fascist.
Oh, yeah. A little hidden. Mhm. Wow.
And then on the left, George Washington.
What are we seeing here? On the right,
fasc.
Yeah, there there should be fascist
somewhere. I put it in there because
there was a fasy fascist. I'm not sure I
can see it on the Washington one. Are we
looking for another symbol here? The
fascia in it. No, it should be
fast.
Huh? Okay. Let's skip to the next one.
The next one.
Uh you you can't see Well, you see it
above the door. Yes. Oh, wow. Yeah.
Right before the triangle. That's the
That's the oval floor, right? Yeah. Wow.
In the White House. Here you see the
House of Representatives
and on the right side you see two bronze
fascists. a symbol of power since the
times of ancient Rome uh hang behind the
the
rotum rostrm in the chamber the fascist
and symbol of the authority of the US
house of representatives it says it says
the same thing as what what you saw of
Rome and it's it's the official website
that I got it from somebody said the
left
pillar maybe
no I have to look it
I I I found I found it. I found
something on it sitting in there. If
anybody can find it unclear a sticker.
Mhm. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And
there you have the the mace what he
talked about. Yeah. And then on the
right side you have the cord and
somebody's holding a fashi.
That's so nuts, man.
And then uh here you see it on the
Statue of Freedom on top of the capital
rotunda. on the right side you see don't
see it on the left but on the right side
you see those uh uh on underneath those
it's like bended those underneath the
foot underneath the foot that yeah those
are the fascists we saw this when we
were in Washington DC we didn't know
what it was so high up there you can
barely see it with a naked eye and I was
like is that an Indian a Native American
or what am I seeing up there no we we
get to that okay believe me and here you
see the department of uh uh uh defense
uh and the United States tax court and
the United States uh Senate. They all
have the fashion fasi fashion. We got
the hat and the freaking hat. Yeah.
Yeah. And the eagle that frigin hat the
roll reefs.
And here you see uh uh on the on both
sides uh you see that with Lincoln. Mhm.
Yep.
And and above if you look on on the top
it says in this temple on the left side
in this temple it says
I'm like okay
wow
whoa military patches.
Yeah military police. Uh yeah it's legal
command. Oh dude the army reserve
police of the army. Yeah it's uh M. Wow.
It's everywhere.
So, we have a Roman. We literally last
time, right? Yeah. And then here, the
apotheiois of Washington. We saw it last
time. But then on the left side, you see
the the the fasci.
Oh, yes.
Yeah. The left lady's hand. Yep.
Wow. Right. And if you guys if you guys
missed the past two shows we did with
Minnow, you got to check those out. Uh
went deep into this what this symbol
means. Obviously you see the as above so
below, but yeah, it's so much deeper.
This is all about deification. It's a
deification ritual ceremony that they
did for Washington where they literally
made him a god. Obviously, he's on
clouds and angels up here blowing
trumpets and stuff, but that's not just
some like fancy illustration. They
literally did a ritual to make him a
god. And Trump de did his inauguration
right under here instead of outside like
everyone else did.
Yeah. Yeah. So, here you see the French
fascist. So, now we go international. So
France and the arms of the French
Republic.
Wow, dude. Oh, okay. And then below it,
it's tucked underneath.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You sometimes
you have to look for it. That's why on
the
left see it. Yeah. It's like this. Oh.
And then the opposite one is the second
one is Yeah. Yeah. Correct.
And then on the on the right side it is
on the top corner. On the right top
corner. All right. The right side. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Oh man.
Got to start looking for him all over.
Yeah, there's a freaking hat. Yeah,
freaking hat. And I think he sits on
It's very unclear on the left. On the
left, but he sits on on the left one. If
you look on the left uh underneath. Yep.
Yep. Under underneath there. Two of the
brown ones. Yeah. It's hard to see. Oh,
yes. And then the coin. Yeah, dude. This
is like a Waldo or Yeah. fascist.
Yeah, it's insane. And and this is
Napoleon, right? And uh this one or this
one? No, this one here. You see the seal
of Napoleon in middle the consulate seal
of Napoleon Bonapart. Wow, dude. Mhm.
And a great seal. And this the round of
Italy fascist eagle in in the middle,
dude. And then there's the Italian
symbol of the social republic. Man, if
you didn't know what you're looking for,
you'd just miss all this. It's like, oh,
it's just eagle standing on a branch or
something.
Yeah. But if you put it all together,
it's like, wow. Right. Yeah.
Italy again, the round and the
shield of somebody.
And here, this is the again Roman armor.
Um, I found so many things. The arms of
the kingdom of Italy. Mhm. the the
coins. What's interesting is it's it's
such a unique weapon. It's it's I mean
it's not just an axe and you could say,
"Oh, you know, people use axes to it's
just an axe." Yeah. Yeah. It's just axe.
No, it's a a wooden barrel basically
wrapped around an axe. Like you you
can't mistake it. It's not something
that we use commonly or anything.
There's no excuse. Mhm. Yeah. No. No.
Wow. Spain. the Spanish Civil Guard on
the Phoenix. Yeah, that's the And then
on the right side say Fius. Fius is uh
Fius is Lithuania or one of those Latia,
Lithuania or something right there.
Wow.
Whoa. And then here Russ. That's Russia.
That's Russia. That's Moscow right here.
Oh, yeah. On the right side.
Um that that thing is in Russia and and
uh and then Pol Poland the blue one.
Yeah. The blue shield. That's Poland.
Yep. You can see him in the background
making an X. Mhm. With the lower.
Yeah. It's crazy. And then the left side
is the Netherlands where I'm from. The
Netherlands.
Netherlands. Yeah. This one is on on the
shield on the red shield. Oh, dude. Oh,
okay. Yeah. Yeah. You have to look for
it sometimes. It's crazy. Yeah. And then
uh it the lion is holding that sh that
uh Yeah. And on the sides. Yeah. Yes.
Mhm. Yeah. It's nuts. And then Ecuador,
Cameroon, Romania. Dude, this literally
proves all roads, all roads lead to
Rome. Well, this proves a one world
order that they've already set up for
many years. Yeah. Yeah.
And then the neofascism in the US is on
the right side. The the
that's the the the patriot front. This
one they just funny that they call it
the out of it.
Yeah. I mean they just used it as their
logo on the flag. Oh yeah. Yeah. And and
here you see it. I talked about the
schools about the the fraternities. This
is the the fraternities the threeletter
uh fraternities, right?
Yes. Yes. Linked freemasonry.
Yep. And on uh on the right side on the
top is on the top of the shield. And
then also the the diapsulin is also on
the top of this above the shield. I knew
I knew school. They always use that
lamp.
That's also on top on the top of the
shield. It's Yeah. Right there. Holding
the owl. The owl. The owl holding it.
Right. The bohemian ground. Nothing to
see there, right? Uhhuh. Nothing to see
there. And this is Italy. This is uh
what you find in Italy uh itself. Some
some some places, some is the palace,
some is architecture, schools, some
bridges, some
wow dude.
And here the fascist symbolism, right?
It's used by uh Hitler and Mussolini.
Mhm.
That that's interesting. I never knew
where that word fascism came from, but
now it totally makes sense.
Yeah. And this is
the the rising sun or whatever. Like you
see this thing all over even in
Washington, ironically enough. They they
put it in patterns in the floor and
you find it all over the world. Um, we
associate it with hate, racism and all
that, but it's sun worship again.
Yeah. And you kind of you can have it
like left and right. Correct. Right.
Mhm.
So left is moon and right is sun. I
didn't know that. Okay. Interesting.
Makes sense.
So uh here this is uh interesting. Um uh
we're jumping a little bit over the all
over but uh because last one was also
Nazism and here you see the Guardian
says not for sale. USPS workers hold day
off action to warn of Trump's illegal
takeover. Well uh he was talking about
taking it over, right? Kind of like uh
uh deciding what to do with the USPS.
What was the first thing that uh that
happened in Nazi Germany? Well, if you
click to the next the next
slide, Adolf Hitler and the Nazi regime
took control of the German postal
service as part of their broader efforts
to consolidate power and control
communication. When Hitler became
chancellor in 1933, interesting 1933,
the Nazis,
yeah, quickly moved to bring all aspects
of government, including the postal
system, the Dutch Reichkes post under
their authority. The postal service was
used for propaganda, censorship, and
surveillance. The Nazis monitored mill
of for dissident activities and
controlled the distribution of
information. They also issued stamps uh
featuring Nazi symbols and Hitler's
image to reinforce their ideology.
Additionally, the Reich's post played a
logistical role in the war effort,
including coordinating communications
and transportation for the military.
Like other state institutions, the
postal system became a tool for the
totalitarian totalitarian regime to
maintain control over German society. H
I'm not saying like uh huh but this is
interesting.
Yeah. Wow, man.
And here you see uh this is something
else also very interesting. So we talked
a little bit about the World Economic
Forum that is kind of like the left-wing
side, right? The left a lot of the
leftist even the right-wingers are are
there but they criticize it. Well, this
is the rightwing part and it's called
the uh the counterpart right-wing
version of the World Economic Forum. The
Alliance for Responsible Citizenship in
short ARC is an international right-wing
organization whose aim is to unite
conservative voices and propose policy
based on traditional western values. It
is associated with psychologist and
political com commentator Jordan
Peterson. It was founded in June 2023
with a London con conference held in
October of that year and a conference in
2025. Now, Jordan Peterson, uh, he's
supposed to be a Christian, right? Yeah,
that's what they say. I don't believe
it, but that's what they say. If you
click to the next,
who is that? This is what does Yeah.
Does it look familiar? Yeah. With
possibly the
sun. Yeah. 2025 conference with Jordan
Peterson and Peter Teal.
And they speak about what? They speak
about the 500 billion invested in
Stargate, Deepseek, and AGI. All about
artificial intelligence.
Yeah, man. We're we're going to have to
really start looking out
for fake Christians in leadership and
uh as role models, Hollywood and all
that stuff because a lot of celebrities
now are coming out as quote unquote
Christian and they have no fruit of
being a Christian. And but this is it's
going to become more mainstream, more
normalized to be a Christian. Whereas
kind of when I was in high school,
everybody was like, I'm I'm an atheist,
you know, it's cool to be an atheist and
I don't believe in God. But now people
are more like I'm spiritual, you know,
like almost the majority of people
believe in something now. Um more
spiritual leaning, new age. I see people
straight up like I saw somebody today
was saying uh throw away your Bible, get
rid of religion, we are gods and all
this stuff. I was like that sounds
familiar. Genesis, the Garden of Eden,
the same lie that was told to Eve. But
what I'm getting at is more people are
open to spiritual
ideas and when they come out with stuff
like now they're saying that the Ark of
the Covenant is real and that the CIA
knows about it since 1988 and stuff like
things are starting to come out now
that's pointing to truths of the Bible.
Um, I can't remember. I seen some other
stuff, too, that was just like proof
that there was a flood and just things
like that. So, it's going to get so
subtle. It's not going to be I mean,
there is some in-your-face stuff like
the the straight up Rome, the straight
up, you know, Hollywood being satanic,
but it's it's only going to push people
towards what they think is God. Yeah,
it's pushing us towards God. But that
alian dialectic, right? Yes. Playing
both sides. You get you playing both
sides. You you go so far to the left
that people are turned off. So they go
all the way swing all the way to the
right and then you got your uh you know
and then and then they they're morphed
into into a solution that that
everybody's happy. Yep. I mean everyone.
Well, and we're going to see with Menow
later as we go into it deeper and from
where I come from even I did an episode
on this. We're going to have to be aware
of this in our churches as some people
bring very strange ideas from the world
into our churches to indoctrinate them
and turn us from the truth. I've already
been through that
um actually. So, it's really hard to
actually wade through it when you're in
it. Yeah. So, we're going to talk more
about that. I have other episodes coming
out a little bit on that, too. But back
to Menow. Sorry. I mean, my my family
grew up in that, too. We went to
condolini churches. They We weren't
trying to we we weren't in yoga or
anything, but it was just your your
average mega church, non-denominational,
charismatic, whatever. And people were
twitching and speaking gibberish and all
that stuff. That's that's a counterfeit.
Mhm.
Yeah. And then so this is uh this is um
the arc uh again is founded by
Baroness Baroness Philip Straout. Uh
yeah 2023 journalist Elanor Mills
described her as the most powerful
right-winger you've never heard of. And
why is that that you never heard of her?
Because she's a baroness.
Oh. Um, what is that? For anybody that
might not know, including myself. Yeah,
that's the next slide. But what is a
baroness? It's a good question. A baron
is I I answered some questions. The
baron is a rank of a no or of nobility
or title of honor
often hereditary, whatever you call
hereditary. Hereditary.
Yeah. In various European countries,
either current or historical, the female
equivalent is a baroness. Typically, the
title denotes an
aristocrat who ranks higher than a lord
or a knight, but lower than a fisc count
or count. Often baronss hold their thief
uh their lands and income directly from
the monarch. Baronss are less often the
vessels of other nobles. In many
kingdoms, they were entitled to wear a
smaller form of a crown called a
coronet.
Isn't that interesting? Super
interesting. Huh?
So you you all of Europe, all these
kings and all these emperors and all
these people are all on the left side.
I've lived in Europe. I'm coming from
Europe. It's all leftwing. And here here
you have a somebody that is a baroness
and part of that
kingdom, you know, uh part of that whole
thing. And she started the right-wing
version.
That's Yeah. Interesting, right?
So, next slide. Uh so this is uh her and
her husband and uh he is uh basically um
uh David Stout her husband is the
founder, trustee and senior leader of
Christ Church London. Here you have the
Christian department uh everything
network and forum and forum uh looks a
little bit more like the N the new
epileic reformation and you see that on
the left top corner uh it's kind of like
uh you know the this is the eight but
seven mountain mandate but you see a lot
of the same slogans like education,
business, government um and that they
have to kind of like uh control or uh
shape the nations of shaped the nation.
That's kind of language in the new
Apostolic Reformation, which is uh
nothing else than Roman dominionism.
Yeah, they got the lint. We actually did
a show on that too, talking about how
all these Hollywood people are suddenly
pushing lint with that um Hello app.
Like you got Marky Mark and Gwen Stefani
and Chris Pratt. Yep. All these people
that claim to be just normal Christians,
but they're all putting ashes on on
their head and saying, "Let's keep
Lent." I never in my life, dude, I've
been in church basically my whole life
besides, you know, some years when I
went prodical, but I never heard any
Christian keeping Lent. I never even
knew what Lent was until I started
looking more into what Catholicism was
and stuff.
And this is and this is Protestant,
right? This is a Protestant church. and
they they uh talk about Lent. Mhm.
Crazy, man. That's what I'm getting at.
The Marky Mark, I don't think maybe him.
I don't know. But Chris Pratt doesn't
claim to be Catholic and I doubt Gwen
Stefan. He's going to an like a seeker
sensitive church. I know exactly which
church. Uh Chad Leaf Chadf uh
California. Uh but he's part of that
whole hillong crowd back then and that
that empire fell. But uh that's all
seeker driven. It's all uh imploded, but
at the same time it's it's exploding
because it's it's very interesting. Uh
people love to go there. Um Wow. But
it's also part of the N
and the Apostolic Reformation. So
So here you see kind of like a couple of
uh interesting people.
Uh then it's a little little bit um not
it's hard to read. Uh so I will not go
into all all these charact but some of
them you will recognize that is the the
the second guy on the left with the eye
patch that's
uh the conservative uh commentator for
Fox News. Isn't he a villain on 007 or
something?
It looks like James Bond movie.
So all these people are like part of the
cabinet and everything. Yeah, they're
they're they're well, no, not not
necessarily Catholic, but Jordan
Peterson is uh and and uh like you have
Mike Johnson, uh Fif on the in the
corner. Uh but then uh the the guy in
the It's bummer that I can I can look
Well, what I will do is I'll go to the
link and I can uh read what uh what what
what is the interesting part of it. One
second. Okay, where are we? Okay. So
important to
note is that uh what is the especially
with
uh
so Alen Ayan here she Ali is the the the
first one on the left and she is from
the Hover Institution uh AHA Foundation
and she she's from the she lived in the
Netherlands. She was a politician in the
Netherlands. Uh that's somebody that
that I I've grown up with. Uh the second
one is actually Dan Krenshaw
and uh he is a a lieut of he was a a
lieut Lieutenant Commander in
SEAL SEAL teams
um house permanent select committee of
intelligence
um and a Fox contributor. And then you
have an important guy here, Edoardo
Ferstei. It's the third one. Um, and he
is a a Mexican
actor and he was
um um Oh yeah. He um who produced the
recent summer hit Sound of Freedom.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And that is a whole other uh uh
interesting thing. It's a whole Mormon
uh uh right
thing that's going on. And we see some
of those people of uh that that that uh
worked on it as well uh later. Uh then
the next one on the list is uh um Jordan
Peterson. Jordan Yeah, Jordan Peterson.
Uh we already know what he's about. Uh
then uh her on the right side here is uh
what was interesting about
her uh I have to uh yeah it's so small I
have to look it up. She speaking in
tongues and stuff. Oh she no she she um
uh so she uh in um she negotiated two
historic agreements. the United States,
Mexico, Canada agreement, the US MCA and
the Abraham Accords
which were a significant step in the
Middle East peace process. Interesting.
Very interesting. And then of course we
have uh speaker of the house at the
moment Mike
Johnson who is also very pro- Israel. Um
then the next guy uh what was his name?
Uh Nicholas Boyce Smith and interesting
about him
uh oh he is the co-chair alongside the
late Sir Roger Scrutin of the
influential building better building
beautiful
where is that language coming from?
Build back better. Yep. This is the
World Economic Forum, right? We're going
to laser your city back as a smart city.
Yeah. Why is the right wing calling
build bad better? Why are they calling
the same things, right? Oh, yeah. Both
sides. Part of the same things. Yeah.
So, the the next guy is Nims Ouna. And
there you have uh he is the the deputy
lieutenant lieutenant of the lord
lieutenant to the uh his majesty king
Charles
II. He is the CEO of the peace alliance
and the senator uh the senior pastor of
freedom's
arc. So very interesting. He is uh uh
very close to the king basically. Uh we
saw that uh that has all to do with
Freemasonry
uh Knights of
Malta, Rome, right? So like very
interesting. We have Philip Stout who is
the Baroness. Mhm. She's the CEO of Arc.
Um
and again she's the Baroness. Then the
next one is interesting because she is
the co co-founding uh she co-founded an
AI focused venture fund uh and is an
angel investor. Um
and she she's currently working studios.
No, no angel investor. So that's kind of
like a a VC a venture capitalist. So
you're you're invest in in in companies.
But this is this is interesting. She's
currently working closely with PRAIS on
building a city. What kind of city?
Smart city.
AI. Yeah. Interesting, isn't it? Wow.
It's so bizarre. And this is this is the
the good guys, the rightwings, the
Republicans, right? Exactly. Yeah. So
then you have Tony Tony Abbott uh and he
the honor honorary Tony Abbott AC served
as the 28th prime minister of
Australia and he is now a director of
Fox Corporation.
Yay.
And then you have your fec
uh of course uh Mr. Doge the next the
the partner of Doge. So that's uh that's
that one. Then if you go to the next
slide. Wow. Then we have this. Yeah.
Then they have the we already saw
Hershey Ali. Then we have we have Bishop
Baron. Yeah. You can just see his outfit
gives him away.
Yeah. Could be a could could have been.
I mean, you know, so
the Lutheran also have a collar, but uh
he also has a a cap on his head, right?
Mhm. So, we got a video on that episode,
by the way. Aubrey circular cap. Yes,
that was that was an interesting episode
for sure.
So the next to the right Brendan McCord
um and he he established the first US
Department of Defensewide applied AI
organization and was founding CEO of two
AI companies acquired for $400 million.
Wow. Interesting. AI AI AI. Yep. I mean
it doesn't matter. You choose
Republican, Democrat. It's
like it's like they just pick clones
for like who is um who's the Democrat
version of Elon Musk, you know? It's
like both both sides you're going to get
the same people just in different skin.
Yep. So the next guy that guy is Eric
Weinstein and he is the the former
managing director of Teal Capital from U
Peter
Thiel. Um then the next guy is uh John
Mackey. Uh he is the co-founder of Whole
Foods Market. Uh and that is uh
basically uh uh Bzos, right? Um make
America healthy again. Yeah. Right. Then
Jordan Peterson again and then the next
line we have Louis Mosley and he is uh
the executive vice president at
Palanteer Technologies which is another
company of Peter Teal.
That's some AI and yeah AI. He oversees
Palanteer's business in the UK and
Europe including Palanteer's UK
government
engagements. His responsibilities
include Palanteer's defense engagements
in Ukraine and across
Europe. Unbelievable. Uh and then you
have your speaker of the house, Mike
Johnson again. And then Neil
Ferguson and uh what was his uh
thing?
Uh quickly going over it. He was also
from the Hoover Hoover in Institute, a
senior fellow.
And I don't know why. What
else? Then the next one is uh
interesting. Nigel Farage, the right
winger from the UK.
And and then next to next to that one is
Peter Thiel himself and he is the
co-founder of uh he was the co-founder
of PayPal. Uh and uh Oh, who was with
PayPal? Oh, that was Elon Musk. Elon
Musk. And oh, who was connected to that?
Oh, yeah. Yeah, there was uh JD fans was
connected there too and he is also of
Palanteer. Somebody in the comments said
they thought PayPal might be connected
with PayPal Rome. I was like I wouldn't
doubt it. I mean it's it's a financial
thing, right? Yeah. Why call it PayPal,
you know?
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Uh also, uh he
made the first outside investment in
Facebook. I thought he was a
right-winger. Oh, but yeah, Mr. Mr.
Zuckerberg was at the inauguration
anyway, right? So, yeah. Um, and has
funded companies like SpaceX
and Stripe. Stripe is a financial thing
that everybody uses on on the web shops.
Wow. And then we have Peter. Peter also
uh started the the foundation which
advances technologies pro techn
technological pro progress and long-term
thinking thinking. Sure. Yeah.
Anyway, unbelievable right then you have
Philipp Stout on the right again. We
talked about her and then we have Tony
Abbott again we and Fac. So you can go
to the next
slide and then these are all people that
are like speaking at some event or
something. Yeah. There um uh so this one
is uh so on the right side you see here
are the 25 2025 panelists and
contributors all the way on the bottom
on the right you see the text it's very
small this all the way on the on the
right right right yeah that's no no the
text I said here are oh I got you are
the 2025 panelists and contributors.
Sorry. Yeah, there were so many people I
couldn't fit it in that much. So, go all
the way on the left corner, left top
corner there is
uh what's his name?
Uh am I now the right one? Angalon or
something. Yeah, he's Yeah, he's
angalos. Archbishop Angalos.
Yeah, Archbishop Angalos. Oh, one
second. It was the same page, but I had
to go to the I had to scroll down. I
clicked out of it. So, yeah, that's
Archbishop Angalos. He is the Coptic
Orthodox uh archbishop of London and
papal leg to the United
Kingdom. Okay.
Uh he is also part of the uh of convert
an OBBE obbe for services to in
international religious
freedom. Lambbeath cross for ecumenism
and coventry cross of nails for
reconciliation. Uh he also serves youth
youth worldwide. So which reconciliation
with the people of with papal row? Yeah,
I don't
know. I don't know. But uh yeah, no
bueno. Uh the next one is Austin Bishop.
He is
um what was Oh, yeah. He is the CEO and
co-founder of the New American
Industrial Industrial Alliance and
general partner at the venture fund
Tamarak Global where he invests across
AI, energy, aerospace, and national
security. He is a former hedge fund
quant trader and co-founder of AI
powered manufacturing company Atomic
Industries.
Funny that AI is coming back multiple
times, right? Yeah. It's all space AI
enslavement.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you remember this guy
Chris Lunsford? Oliver Anthony, the
artist, he was complaining about taxes
that we pay too many taxes, right? Yeah.
Yeah. That song that that conservative
song, right? I don't know him, but I
I've seen him I've seen videos being
passed around by Republicans and stuff.
Yeah. But, uh, anyway, he's part of this
this whole thing as well. And then you
have Chris Power on the right. Uh he's
the founder and CEO of Hadrien, a
company transforming US defense and
aerospace
manufacturing. Oh man, always always
space man. Yeah, I know.
We have to defend the earth against the
evil alien invader Jesus Christ. So
yeah, I know, right? He he basically
he's out of space. He's not in in not on
Earth right now.
So uh the next one is Daniel Rniki and
he is the leading investment banker. Uh
he is dealing with depth markets.
Interesting. If you create depth and
then you buy it and then you you know
make money off of it. Um
what else was interesting? And then he
Oh, this was interesting as well. He's a
classic liberal.
Interesting. Huh? What? Classic liberal.
What? Yeah, classic liberal. Okay. I
didn't know that uh that you are on the
right wing if you're classic liberal.
Not a neoliberal classic one. Yeah, I
guess. I guess uh David Stout, the
husband of uh Mrs. Stout again and we
already talked about him. Uh next line
is Eric Mataxis and he is uh an apostle
in the movement of the NR new apostolic
reformation pushes that very hard. Uh
next one is Eric Eric Prince and he's an
interesting guy. He is part of the CNP,
the Council for National Policy. We
touched on that last time a little bit
and that's also part of that whole
Mooney thing, the cult from South Korea.
uh and uh who invested it in it and Tim
Lehei was on uh you know founded that
organization. It's kind of like the the
right-wing think tank competitor
compared with the with the Club of Rome
and uh and um
um build oh the Bilderberg not
Bilderberg and all that the rightwing
version.
So, Eric Prince uh is an American
businessman, investor, and former US
Navy Seal officer and founder of the
private military company Blackwater. H
Blackwater, Blackstone, Black Rockck,
what Black
Black um anyway, he wanted to privatize
the u the Secret Service. uh uh he he
proposed that to Trump I believe but it
didn't not yet at least but uh who knows
if he can push it through. Then on the
right you have uh James
Pulos. Uh he's a tech a tech theorist
and media media
practitioner practi practitioner media
practitioner.
Interesting.
Um and wasn't wasn't it Georgetown
University? Was that a Jesuit
organization?
I'm not sure. I'm not 100% sure. But
anyway, uh I found it interesting. Oh,
that was interesting. He is the editor
at large at Blaze Media.
Oh, okay. Blaze. Yeah. Is that what is
that from? Um, uh, back. Yeah. The Yeah,
Morland. Then the next to the right you
have J Jenny
Allen and she
is Oh, yeah. She's a uh she's a dame of
Malta and of the Constantinian order. H
what do we talked about last time? I
believe Mhm. the Jesuits and the the
noble uh the the black nobility and the
tech the aristocrat family
part of the Malta and and the
Constantinian order. Knights of Malta
and um you say Constantine something
like that. No. Yeah. The Constantinian
order. Yeah, we did talk about that last
time.
Yeah. The the Duke that was visiting
Trump was part of the house that had to
do with the um the counterreformation
and it's very
interesting. But anyway, the next one on
the on the on the right is Mr. Jeffrey
or Jeff Harmon. He is the co-founder and
chief content officer of Angel Studios.
Oh, interesting. Studio behind the hits
like Sound of Freedom and The Chosen.
The Chosen. Yeah. Which is all about
ecumenicism run by half Catholic, half
Mormon.
It's crazy, dude. And Jesuits and and
Knights of Yeah. I mean, whatever. the
actor that plays Jesus that everybody
pictures in their mind when they pray.
Now they literally people say that every
time I pray I see him uh who says that
he was kned as a the highest level
knights Templar and on the same higher
than a 33 degree Freemason. Mhm. Talks
to the dead. Also he Yeah. Talks to the
dead. He also said that he was going to
be kned uh in Vatican as well to as a
Vatican for the Vatican order or
something like that. Uh I have footage
of that as well. It's insane. It is
insane. And he went to the Pope with
with the Dallas Jenkins. Yeah, that
Yeah, I saw that too.
Yeah, that's And then on the right side
you have
um Jordan Harmon. That's his brother,
co-founder and president of Angel
Studios.
Mhm.
So, that's uh interesting. And then
uh on the Yeah, that that one is also a
Jordan uh F Jordan. Uh um what's his
name? Um uh what's his name now?
This this guy I'm pointing at is Jordan
Herman.
Yeah, Jordan Herman. He's also part of
the he's also uh part of that uh family.
So let me see. So it's crazy. Yeah. That
all of this is
pushing space exploration or weaponizing
space and AI governance and
uh the angel studios like a a a
universal religion basically. Mhm. Yeah.
That's pushed through propaganda like
high budget production value and all
that.
Yep. And then on on the right side
you've got the
Noel Noel her uh Herman that's also a
brother. So three of them are uh are in
there. It's crazy. Wow.
So then uh if we go back uh to the top
row, not the middle row. Yeah, that guy.
I skipped
him.
Uh where is he? Oliver Durr.
Yeah, Oliver Durr. He
is Where is he? Oliver
Durr. Oliver Dur, where are you?
Yeah, he is the director of center for
faith and
society. Uh oh, that's the interesting.
He is uh he is a theologian, historian,
author and filmmaker who researches
transhumanism. What this the cultural
implications of AI and how to live well
in the digital age. Okay.
Yep.
And then next there you have Satty Huff,
which is also known as Robertson from uh
the the Robertson's uh the those
hillbillies on TV on Fox News. Oh. Um
the Duck Dynasty people. The Duck
Dynasty. Yeah. She's from that family.
She she believes that uh that she's from
the Church of
Christ or Church of Christ or that or
something. She her denomination believes
that bapti baptism saves.
So it's interesting. But uh yeah, she's
also very in the crowd of uh of uh of
the N as well and connected there. When
when you know what you're looking for,
man, all the pieces are falling into
place. But there's so many Christians
that just don't have a clue about the
stuff that that you know God has
revealed to us about this
universalist one world religion that
looks Christian.
Yeah. Yeah. So the next guy there that
you're pointing at now is let me see
here Johans's heart or something. Yeah.
Johan. Yeah. Jo Jonah Johannes Hardle uh
German philosopher, theologian, speaker
and author. Uh he is considered one of
the most influential medi mediators
between Christianity Christian
spirituality, philosophy and psychology
in the German speaking
area. Like spirituality, there you have
it again, right? Yeah. Okay. Oh my
goodness. The next one is uh Mr. Kevin
Roberts, Mr. 2025 project 2025. Okay.
Wow.
He is uh he is the the the founder of
the oh no the president of the Heritage
Foundation and Heritage Action for
America and also uh previously
previously served as the CEO of the
Texas Public Policy Foundation and
president of Wyoming Catholic College.
He's a Catholic obviously
of course. So interesting.
Yeah. And what is the next one here?
Scott the
Yeah. Oh, Scott. Yes. Yep. He He was the
Scott Morrison. Uh served as Australia's
30th prime minister, Treasurer, Minister
of for Social Services, Minister for
Immigration and Bordom Protection, and
as a member of the Australian
Parliament.
And this is
interesting because he is also Scott now
works in the private sector providing
strategic advice to corporations in
various se sectors including
defense, space, infrastructure,
resources and funds management.
Interesting. And uh on top of that he
his pastor was Brian Houston from
Hillsong. Oh yeah. Wow. Yeah. So there's
the N connection again. Yeah.
And then you have Tammy Peterson. That's
uh Jordan Peterson's wife. Really?
That's interesting as well. Yep. It
looks She looks like a man in this
picture. But she looks like that lady.
Man, I can't remember her name, but the
one that's riding with blood all over
the walls and she's always connect.
Yeah. Brahmovich.
Yeah. Uh um Marina Abramovich. Uh next
episode we'll um have her in in the
video. Oh, okay.
So um but yes. Yeah, she's she she looks
like a man, but she's a woman for sure.
I guess I hope she does.
Um but anyway, so next
slide. What do we have there? Oh yes,
now we go back to Rome. uh the
US the image. So the Supreme Court, it's
interesting that um the Supreme Court of
the United States has nine justices as
of May 2023. There were that there were
seven Catholic justices on the US court
supreme court or there are I don't know
why I said there were there are and the
these justices are chief justice John
Roberts of uh Clarence Thomas Samuel
Alito Neil Gorsuch Brett Kavanaaugh Amy
Coney Barrett and Sonia Maria Maria
Stoayor and then the only one that's
Protestant but doesn't know what a woman
is is Katanji Brown accent.
Interesting. But she's Catholic
friendly. And then a Jewish person,
Elena
Kagan. So one one Jewish person, one
Protestant, and the rest all Catholic.
Yeah. It's just representation to say
they're being fair. Catholic takeover,
right? Yeah. Is that not Rome taking
over here? And again, we talked about
this. We talked about this last last two
times. Like if you are a Catholic,
you're swearing allegiance to first the
pope.
Yeah.
So are you on the Supreme Court then
first doing Catholic? Is is your
Catholicism done not first go going
first, you know,
above the US rule? Right. Right. I don't
know. It's
interesting.
And they serve on both sides. It doesn't
matter. They look like a bunch of popes
anyway.
Huh? They They look like a bunch of
popes anyway. The way they're dressed.
Black popes. Yeah, the black pope. Yeah.
Yeah. So, this one is interesting. So
there outside you have the statue a
contemplation of justice and that statue
on the Supreme Court Plaza. The
portrayal of a female figure
representing justice dates back to
depict
depictations. Sorry depictions.
Oh you have me thrown off. That's a
foreign word right there. I don't know
of Theis and just
justicia in as an ancient uh uh
mythology and Theis known for her
clearsightedness was the Greek goddess
of justice and good in Roman
mythology justicia justice was one of
the four virtues along with prudence
fortitude and temperance is Christianity
yeah right this is something that is an
America again points back to Rome. And
we found all of those on the ceiling of
the um Library of Congress painted
there. Check out Washington DC exposed
video. All this stuff, man. It's it's
all goes back to Rome. Mhm.
Yep. So the next slide we have uh this
the statue authority of law also called
the guardian of executor of law. Fraser
described the mill figure uh to the
right of the steps as powerful, erect
and vigilant. He wait he waits uh with
concentrated attention holding in his
left hand the tablet of laws backed by
the uh sheetated sword symbolic of
enforcement through law. The Latin word
for law lax is inscribed on the tablet.
Why a Latin word? Why not in English?
Because Latin is Latin is Catholic which
is Rome.
Yeah. Oh man.
Unbelievable. Uh interesting fun fact.
The tablets of Lex does mean law and
Superman fights against the villain
named Lex Luthther. So Superman is
fighting against the law. It's just
another one of those like Gnostic plot
twists. Oh wow. Yeah. You going to the
next slide? The law of Luther.
Yeah. Right.
Luther fighting against Luther who who
defended the law basically, right? Wow.
I didn't put that together. Yeah. Next
slide. Interesting. Wow. That's just a
word play, right? Yeah. Yeah. Next
slide. Yeah, you can do the next slide.
So, Lady Justice, the origin of Lady
Justice was Justicia or uh Eosticia, the
goddess of justice within Roman
mythology.
Justicia was introduced by Emperor
Augustus. Hey, and was thus not a very
old deity in the Roman pantheon. Justice
was one of the virtues celebrated by
emperor Augustus in his uh clipus fert
fertitis and a and a temple of
justicitia was established in Rome by
emperor Tiberius. Justicia became a
symbol for the virtue of justice with
which every emperor wished to associate
his regime. Emperor
uh Vespassian minted coins with the
image of the goddess seated on a throne
called Yustitia Augusta. And many
emperors after him used the image of the
goddess to proclaim themselves
protectors of justice through a though
formerly called a goddess with her own
temple and cult shrine in Rome. It
appears that she was uh from the one
from the onset viewed more as an
artistic symbolic personification rather
than as an actual deity with religious
significance. Uh the ancient Egyptian
book of the dead depicts a scene in
which a deceased person person's heart
is weighed against the feather of truth.
Wow. On the left. Oh, you see it on the
left
again. Rome and Egypt, it's all pointing
back to the same thing. All roads lead
to Rome. That's right. Here you see the
the figures of justice portraying
justice as a female figure dates back to
depict depictions of Atheis, the Greek
goddess of justice and law. Did we just
talk about this?
Yeah, it's a it's a Yeah, it's it's
another another one. Over time, justice
became associated with uh with scales to
represent uh impartiality and a sword to
symbolize power. During the 16th
century, justice was often portrayed
with a blindfold and today it is
accepted as a symbol of impartiality.
Who got blindfolded? Oh, the Freemasons,
right? The female figure represent Yeah.
Uh uh the female uh figure representing
justice is one of the most recognized
legal symbols visible at Supreme Court
building and is depicted in three
sculptural groups.
Dude, this is and it's again uh it is
one of the four for virtuous Roman
things. This is the door. So, the bronze
door and um where is this door located?
On on what building or
that's the the same building? Supreme
Court. Oh, this is all we're still at
the Supreme Court. Yeah, it's it's
crazy. So, the shield the shield of
Achilles.
Uh I mean uh what else? Uh Makna Carta.
Um what else? the it's a little bit
small just but everything is Rome a lot
I mean Julian and Scholola Julian one of
the most prominent law teachers in
ancient Rome uh Ptor edict
yeah Ptor's edict a Roman Prater
magistrate so
it's a lot of uh a lot of Roman stuff in
here again.
And next slide here you see the great
hall freeze and uh book uh book and
torches on the left education and
knowledge. Solomon and wisdom and
magnific magnificent and magnificence.
Uh Solomon uh probably in his late
uh state, right? Right. Once he got
corrupted by all those pagan women and
everything. Yeah. Yeah. Correct. Because
uh if you go down, you see here the owl
and and Juno. Mhm. I mean, what does
Salomon has to do with an owl and Juno?
Nothing. And the owl is Moolok and the
Bohemian Grove. Worship them. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And the owl also has the
lower reef there. And then also on the
on the left top you see the book of
torches and the torches. What does the
torches represent? Lucifer. That's
Lucifer's torch. Yeah. Mhm. Yeah. Which
can be seen at the Olympics and the
Statue of Liberty. Yeah.
Yeah. Wow, dude. Next slide. the east
freeze and um here you see that's you
can't read it but uh again they see a
fas fashy I believe and
um nothing Christian let's say that way
right some symbolism there and some some
people that has nothing to do with
Christianity
let me see if I can read any of it oh it
says
holding the fascis a Roman symbol
full of authority. Yeah.
Wow. Again, Rome.
Yep. And the West freeze uh again
uh you see the two central female
figures uh are justice
again and
divine. A winged figure, a winged
figure, right? What is a winged figure?
I mean, angels don't have wings. Doesn't
say it, right? A wing figure. Just
because it's an angel doesn't mean it's
good either.
Yeah. True. And a divine inspiration uh
holding the scales of justice again.
Divine inspiration and then uh just of
um skills
uh
wisdom south. Then you see Moses. What
does Moses have to do? Menace and
confusion. I saw this on the the
ceiling. I pointed it out of the Library
of Congress as well when we were there.
Yeah. They see him as a a prophet or a
lawgiver, right? Because he gave the
law. Mhm. But then
again, which law, right? It's almost
like um just a fairy tale for law. Like
where did we get the law? Well, there
was this guy named Moses. Like where did
the babies come from? Well, he's a
stork. You know, it's it's just a an
image to them.
Yeah. Crazy. The next slide. Uh then we
have the North Freeze. There you have
King John, which is interesting. The uh
they say that all presidents lead to
King John.
I never knew that.
Oh, sorry. Are you talking about that?
There was a kid, a girl, I think like 12
years old that made this circular chart
with Obama and it was like all
presidents have the same ancestors or
something. Yep. Yep. Wow. And it's known
that that all the pre presidents go back
to King John. So it's the bloodline,
royal bloodline. Yeah, bloodline. Yeah.
Crazy. And then uh here you see the the
tablets of law. Uh looks like the ten
commandments. Uh symbolism is again
Rome, right? The Roman letters, Roman
numerals. Yeah. Oh, but interestingly
enough on the very bottom it has on top
of that tablet of stone it says the nu
Roman numerals. It has the sun first.
Does it? Yeah. Sun rays. Oh my goodness.
It does. And the eagle back there. Mhm.
So Rome. Yes. Sun worship. The the eagle
is Rome. Victory. Yeah.
Wow. And instead of the the ten
commandments, it says the tablets of the
law, right? And it looks like 10 as if
it is the ten commandments. Yeah. 10.
Yeah. The reliefs and external medians
and uh at and the the and the great
freeze. Yeah. Again, Roman Roman
Manurva. Um what's that? The shield um
of the helmet. Yeah. This is a Roman
helmet with the bristles on top and
everything.
Uh book and the torches again. Um
this Hermes right here. Mhm. Yeah.
Mercury is Hermes. They're both
depending on if you're looking at Rome
or Greek.
Yeah. And then Juno and Zeus, Solomon,
the eagle and the owl. It's
unbelievable. This is flashbacks to when
we were in Washington. You guys got to
check that. If you're interested in this
at all, check out the Washington video
because we got
video of a huge Zeus statue right
outside the entrance.
What was that? Did you look at number
one? Yeah. Uh, Thunderbolt. What's that
representing? That's Satan
fell
like falling from heaven,
man. We got Moses. Just throw throw him
in there.
Yeah, Moses and uh and Solomon again. Oh
man,
unbelievable. And here again, you see uh
uh let's see here.
Um what was this? The
uh again, Moses, Confucious, and Solen.
Oh my goodness.
It's just like, hey, um let me give you
this painting. It's got some some words
of Jesus, Buddha, and Confucious. Like,
you would never hang that in your house.
Yeah, but Yeah, there's Moses. It's a
Christian nation. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
That's really all it is. It's like they
throw a Christian character in there
just to let down the guard of the
Christians. And this is something that
we've been seeing for a long time and we
see it again. Disney now has a Christian
character in a TV show supposedly. They
said they they were going to use a uh a
transgender character, but at the last
minute changed it to a Christian cartoon
character, but in the in the show, her
mom is reading her tarot. And then
today, by just circumstance, I I was
looking for something to play. We're
always trying to find we're people, you
know, we like to watch things. We know
there's nothing really good to watch.
So, we go back to old times and there
was a movie called The Bishop's Wife. I
was like, "Oh, it's maybe it's good.
It's about a a wife who's her and her
husband are having problems and an angel
comes to help them fix their marriage."
Sounds like a good storyline. For one,
the angel's falling in love with the
wife. So, you you already have and then
she's falling in love with him and he's
So, it's like angel adultery going on.
He's got magic. Every time he turns
around to do something for the people,
it's like a magical thing that happens
or to keep her husband away from her so
that he can have more time with her and
so on. Yeah. Oh, he keeps saying like,
"Oh, we got to take the long way home
and stuff." But the craziest part is 36
minutes into the movie, 36 I think is
interesting,
uh, they're at a restaurant. He goes,
"Have you ever had your palm read?"
She's like, "Oh." He's, "Let me see your
palm." The angel from heaven is reading
poems.
This is nothing new, man. Satan has been
trying to because his attack, his focus
is not on the world. The world's already
lost. They're already partying,
drinking, fornicating, all that. His
main focus is how can I make the
Christians stumble? How can I deceive
them? Okay, I'm going to use this
entertainment just like us. We were
looking for something fun to watch or
whatever. And bam, there it is.
uh palm reading all of a sudden and now
Disney tarot cards. You know, we have to
muddy the waters and and combine
paganism, occultism, Rome with
Christian. And I will just add that
movie had, if you've seen A Wonderful
Life, we know it was made during this
time, the same time period almost
because they had some of the same actors
from that old black and white movie,
It's a Wonderful Life, when it was made.
And so it's been planned from the very
beginning to actually take something
that looks Christian to get into your
mind and be like, "Oh, I can sympathize.
It's a good movie. It's an angel." and
change it, flip it on its head to get it
into people's minds and into their
lives. So, it was incredible to see
that. And I'm sure that movie is like
rated G, you know. It's like
Yeah. Wow. And and that ties also re
really closely in with uh with um uh the
N New Apostolic Reformation. They use
prophecy. They call it prophecy, but
it's uh divination, right? like fortune
telling like uh oh you're going to be
rich for the Lord and you're going to do
this and I saw a flower and the flower
opened up and it's your life and you're
going to flourish and yeah exactly I've
seen those crazy things man yeah and and
from the states right from the states
like oh I see a flower
the next one the east prim or the west
which one are we doing the west
uh as at the far left. Uh so here the
the three central figures from the left
to the right are uh are order liberty
and um
enthroned and
authority and let's see here what was
yeah so at the far left is the chief
justice William Howard Taft representing
research uh presc research Prescott
present
he is portrayed as a student at Yale's
University. Okay. Yale a long time.
Yeah.
And and is facing an English
crown. Okay. Uh a pope's miter. Wow. And
a bishop's uh a bishop's croier. At the
far right is Chief Justice John Marshall
representing researchers past. He is
holding Roman scrolls and gazing at an
at an ern mosaic t tables and an oil
lamp resting at his feet. What? Okay.
Okay. So, you got a pope with you got um
goddesses of order, liberty, bishop.
Yeah. The bishop. Yeah. Oh my goodness.
And here you have Yeah. Christianation.
Uh second second from the left is
Senator Alihu Root representing council
Root introduced President theft's bill
to create Washington's fine arts
commission Cass Gilbert uh the architect
of the Supreme Court building and the
third figure from the left is shown
talking to Ruth third from the right
also representing council in Chief
Justice Charles Evans huge who served as
chairman of the Supreme Court building
commission. Huge is shown talking to
Robert Atkins, sculpture of the uh
piment pediment. Uh and the second
figure on on the right and nothing to do
with Christianity, man. Wow, dude.
That's the gist of it. Yeah. Uh
courtroom freezes, east and west walls
again. Uh same things like bigger. The
way this looks, this looks so Nazi,
which Nazism is just Roman or Roman
temples, right? It's Mhm. Yeah.
Wow, dude.
Oh, this uh it's too small. But uh
Mohammed, I see I see uh uh Louis 4th,
which was a king of France. We get into
him in the next episode, I think. King
John
again. I
mean, do I see Christ here anywhere? No.
Well, where's Baldo? That's the thing.
When you go there, you'll see every god
except the true God. Every god but
Christ and it's just nuts. It's all
humanism. And Moses is there. Yeah,
Moses. Moses is there. That's
man. So anyway, so here you see the
Lincoln Memorial built in 1922 is also
based on the architecture of ancient
Rome. Yeah, it
features it features uh um let's see
here
uh 36 Doric columns used in ancient
Greek and Roman architecture. Oh, 36.
Yeah. Yeah. One second. 36
triple six. uh columns commonly used in
ancient Greek and Rome architecture.
Other than that, the White House,
Central Park, Boston Public Garden,
Supreme Court building, and Jefferson
Memorial also reflect Roman
architecture.
Wow, man. The mirror of Rome, the image
of the beast.
Exactly. Roman education inspired
American education educational reformer
Horus man who advocated advocated for
establishing a public education system
that would offer a fundamental education
to all kids regardless of their social
status or upbringing during the colonial
era. The United States adopted the Roman
classical educational system which
remained a pillar of American education
until the early 20th century or until
now. Basically, it's just indoctrination
camps. I mean, used to parents raise
their children. you know, the you're
supposed
to work in the garden and have the kids
teaching the kids skills that actually
do something in their life. And like how
to build a house, how to grow your food,
how to get water, how to survive through
the winter, and the mom's teaching how
to cook, and how to
uh you know, take care of wounds or
whatever and teach.
But no, now the state owns your
children. If your children don't go to
the the public school system, wait a
minute, you're going to get a knock on
the door, letters in the mail. You're
going to go to court and maybe have your
kids taken away. You better get them in
the Roman education system.
They own your own in the Netherlands. In
the Netherlands, uh, until 18 years,
until you're 18, you you have to go to
school. Yeah. There's no there's no uh
homeschooling really. No option. Huh?
Even when you homeschool though, the
only way you can home is if you Not that
I'm aware of. Yeah. The only way you can
really legally homeschool is if you get
a curriculum that's under a certain
umbrella. You're you're they call it an
umbrella school system or whatever. So,
you're you're just indoctrinating
yourself in your home at that point. I
mean, they might let you do some
creationism or whatever, but you're
still going to learn all the same stuff.
Yeah. Crazy. What's What's
next? Uh, the Pentagon. Yay. And the
Roman war machine. Rome was not built on
law alone. It was enforced by legions.
Mhm. So two is Washington DC protected
by a structure built in their image, the
Pentagon. With it five-sided symmetry
and fortified design, the Pentagon
mirrors the Roman castm, a military fort
built for efficiency, command, and rapid
mobilization. The hierarch hierarchial
command structure of the US military
reflects the Roman system of centurions
generals and ultimately the empower of
emperor himself. In today's terms,
centralized military authority lies in
the hands of a few ready to exercise
power over the many. sources, evidence
tracing the Roman his uh Roman military
nexus. Uh the Roman origins of US
military um uh uh phil philosophy are
are no secret. Then you have the the
Edward N. Lutz, the grand strategy of
the Roman Empire shows how modern
defense systems mirror Roman designs.
Steve Fogle's The Pentagon. Uh I I
assume they're books. Uh uh history
documents the architectural and tactical
uh lineage of the US military. And then
the Department of Defense itself, the
archives even referenced the Roman
Republic. I said it in the beginning,
right? Wow. Our republic, Roman Republic
is nothing new.
It's just you said the republic the
whole the whole creation of a republic
was from Rome was from Rome as an
inspiration for military organization
and leadership models. The intent was
always has has always been clear to
build an empire of influence that draws
from the most power powerful system ever
devised by man. Rome. Rome.
This is so in your face man. I guess
that was the end. Yes, we are back. That
was the end of this episode. Wow. You
guys got to stick around for part two.
Roads lead to Rome. Oh, man. So, we're
doing part two. The image, right? We
talked about it in the beginning. The
image of the beast. You see it the
education war uh the the Pentagon the
the the government everything is you
know it's it's it's we have to take over
government for Christianity it's already
there. Yeah. Yeah. The model for Rome is
already there like you're saying and
ready to be taken over again. Yeah. All
the soldier patches have the fascist on
their I mean they're Roman soldiers. And
I don't know if anybody's here that just
doesn't understand prophecy the way we
understand it, but when you really study
out who is the beast, it's it's not a
man. People get that wrong. A beast is a
kingdom. You find that out in Daniel
because God gives all these prophecies
and symbols. There's not really beast
rising out of the sea. There's not
really a woman riding a seven-headed
dragon. There's not really a woman
standing on the moon clothed with the
sun. These are all symbols and the Bible
interprets those symbols and tells you
Daniel says a beast is a kingdom. So
when you're trying to identify who is
the beast, you're identifying a kingdom.
That kingdom is dressed in purple and
scarlet. You look at the Well, let's not
go right into that. Okay. First, the
beast is represented by iron. That's in
the statue of Nebuchadnezzar. that's in
the fourth beast with iron teeth. And
then it's it's all these parallels
repeat and enlarge. You see a woman, a
corrupt woman, which a woman is a
church. This is a corrupt church sitting
on a beast with seven heads. And it says
that the seven heads are seven hills.
What's the city of seven hills? Look it
up. Google it. What is the city of seven
hills? Rome. Okay. So, we're looking for
a corrupt church in Rome who uh has
persecuted the saints. You look back in
history, they killed millions of
Christians, dressed in purple and
scarlet, drinks out of a golden cup,
decked with golden precious stones. Just
type in purple scarlet church. You'll
see exactly who it is. The Catholic
bishops says purple, right? Purple and
scarlet. I don't know any church. No,
you just type it in purple scarlet
church. You'll see Catholic bishops and
cardinals wearing the purple and
scarlet. You'll see the building is
decked with gold and precious stones.
It's the only one. There's no other
system, no other church, no other
corrupt church that sits on City of
Seven Hills dressed in purple and
scarlet except Vatican Rome paple Rome.
And so we know that the the beast Rome
it suffered a fatal head wound and it is
reviving. It's it's definitely healthy
and well in here because all the
American presidents, all the presidents
and leaders of the world fly over to
meet with the pope. Why? Because that's
who's in control. Mhm. But we know that
we're looking for another system, a
beast that rises out of the the earth
later. That's America. There's no other
no other nation fits this lamblike or
Christian-like nation that speaks like a
dragon which represents Satan and Rome
and is going to make a mirror or an
image to Rome. We just saw in this
presentation America is Rome. It's the
world superpower and it's a literally
mirror image of Rome and it's pointing
all people to Rome. That's what a
prophet does. That's why it's known as
the false prophet. America is the false
prophet. America is the second beast
that points all people to the first
beast. And there's a a system being set
up
of one world religion, one world
government, and everyone is going to bow
down to that beast system. Because if
you don't worship this
way, you're a problem to humanity. You
don't believe in peace. You don't
believe in unity. You don't believe in
coexist. So, you get punished. No more
buying and selling for you. Thrown in
prison and eventually beheaded. And this
is just a a repeat of history because
when you look up the history of the blue
laws, that is a a law put in place to
where you cannot buy or sell on Sunday,
the venerable day of the sun.
Constantine. Trump is the new
Constantine. It's all coming back
around. If you didn't, what the blue law
said in the
1400s was if you don't attend church
every Sunday morning and evening, the
first attempt, the first uh punishment
was having your allowance cut off. No
buying and selling. Second second
punishment was whipped. And third
punishment was death. It's exactly what
Revelation says. If you don't worship
this way, no buying and selling,
persecution, death. And so when you look
at blue laws, they're they're all over
the world. They're in they're in place.
Someone just has to come in and activate
that. And that wasn't going to be
accepted years ago. But now that we've
had this far left swing and everybody's
sick of it, I'm sick of all the 86
genders and trans and you're shoving all
this stuff down our throats. like we
need change. Trump's bringing that
change. And I'm not pointing out Trump.
It's the whole system. They're puppets.
They're working for Satan. Demons in the
White House. It's that's what the Bible
says that Satan is the god of this
world. And if you don't believe that,
then you've been duped.
Well, and and also think about it like
which country in the world is policing
the world? There's no country in the
world that is that is policing the
world. That's the US. That's
right. And I mean, they're already
saying, "Oh, China, this, China, that,
Russia, this, Russia, that, Iran, blah,
blah, blah." Yeah. Boogie. Who's
policing everything? Who's every who who
who is keeping everyone in check? That's
right. US. Yep. Sending America to save
the day. And they're saying that now
with Trump that he he can save the
world.
Wow, man. Dude, this has been super eye
opening, especially if if people just
aren't paying attention at all and this
is kind of the first time they've seen
any of this. This is like
flipping your world upside down.
Um, everything we've believed is a is a
lie. You know, Satan's a master
deceiver. And ultimately, this is
the dragon is wroth with the woman, the
remnant who keep the commandments of
God. If we stand on thus sayith the
Lord, if we obey God's commandments and
we do everything that God asks us to do,
Satan is going to hate you and he's
going to try to attack you and kill you.
And that's that's his main attack is
those
faithful. He's creating a system of a
bunch of lukewarm people that in the
last days Jesus going to say, "I never
knew you. You workers of lawlessness.
You workers of iniquity." And so I just
pray that people will start to take
their relationship with Christ serious.
Get in God's word. Get in prayer. Jesus
coming soon. Let's stop messing around,
man. It's time to get serious about our
walk.
and get out of her, my people. That's
right. Get out of her. Get into the
country. Grow your own food. We're in
the country. We're we're we're planting
seeds. We're getting ready.
All right. Well, that's all I had for
today, man. Thank you so much. Keep our
episode coming, though. Yes. Thank you
so much for all your research. I'm
looking forward to tomorrow we do part
two, which is actually part four. Mhm.
Yeah. And this is going to be it's going
to be awesome, man. Yeah. Thank you so
much. You're welcome. Fantastic. Well,
thanks uh thanks so much for having me
on and uh looking forward to tomorrow.
All right, man. See you then, bro. Thank
you. Thank you guys for joining us at
Truth to the Youth. If you like this
video, please give it a thumbs up. It
really helps get this video out into the
algorithm. If you're new, you saw
something you like, please click that
subscription button and the little uh
bell icon so you won't miss another
video. And share this with your family
and friends. This is important
information that needs to get out there.
If you'd like to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got multiple ways to
give. If you like t-shirts, we got some
cool t-shirts on the website with
scripture and encouraging just phrases
and things. And we teach that it's cool
to use your brain. Satan doesn't want
you to think. Everything's a distraction
to keep you from using your brain. We
say it's cool to use your brain, which
is why the logo is a brain man with some
sunglasses. But we love you guys. We
can't do this without you. Your support
matters to us. And we'll see you next
time on Candid Truth.